Hi, hey.
Hey, hi.
I don't mean to bother you guys or anything, but I'm going to start a podcast.
I'd love a little help.
I don't know if you guys are busy, but...
No, I guess I could jump in.
What's the podcast called?
Well, we just sit and talk and visit, you know?
嗨，嘿。嘿，嗨。我不是故意打扰你们什么的，但我打算做一个播客。我想要一点帮助。我不知道你们是不是很忙，不过……不，我想我可以加入。这播客叫什么名字？嗯，我们就是坐在一起聊天、串门，你知道的？
What's it called?
I love to visit.
Well, I'm not bright, right?
So, kind of...
I'm thinking about unsmart.
Oh, that's good.
But it doesn't really roll off the...
I'm without smarts.
叫什么名字？我喜欢串门。嗯，我不太聪明，对吧？所以，有点……我在考虑“不聪明”。哦，那挺好的。但它听起来不是那么顺口……我没有智慧。
So I'm...
You don't have more smart.
No, I'm less than smart.
So what do you...
Maybe...
Maybe dumb out.
Less smart.
Let's come out with us later.
所以我是……你没有更多的聪明。不，我连聪明都算不上。所以你觉得……也许……也许叫“变笨”吧。不太聪明。我们待会儿一起出来吧。
Let's do the show.
We'll come out with later.
Okay, great.
Welcome to it all the new smart list.
Smart.
Less smart.
Hey, Willie, did you just barely make it?
Hold on.
我们开始做节目吧。我们待会儿出来。好的，太棒了。欢迎来到全新的“智能榜”。智能。不太聪明。嘿，威利，你是不是差点就赶不上了？等等。
We have...
He's not out of breath.
Will audio.
Do we have Will audio?
Oh, audio?
Will audio.
Will audio?
I made it.
我们有……他没喘粗气。音频。我们有威利的音频吗？哦，音频？威利的音频。威利的音频？我赶到了。
We got Will audio.
I made it, I made it, I just ran out of the car, I made it.
You guys, I made it, I was on the...
You were on the freeway?
I was on the LIE, guys.
I was on the LIE, just keeping it real.
You know, you're lying.
Did you ever see that movie, by the way?
我们弄到威利的音频了。我赶到了，我赶到了，我刚从车里跑出来，我赶到了。伙计们，我赶到了，我在……你在高速公路上？我在LIE（长岛高速），伙计们。我在LIE，保持真实。你知道的，你在撒谎。顺便问一句，你看过那部电影吗？
L.I.E. Brian Cox plays like a child molester?
Incredible movie.
What?
I know I didn't see it, man.
I didn't want to start with that, but...
Wait, what are you talking about?
There's some horrible story.
Let's talk about it.
《L.I.E.》（长岛高速公路）。布莱恩·考克斯演一个恋童癖？不可思议的电影。什么？我知道我没看过，老兄。我本来不想以这个话题开头的，但……等等，你在说什么？有些可怕的故事。我们来聊聊吧。
When did that come out?
Oh, 20 years.
years ago, I'll bet.
Okay.
Shani, I just narrowly missed seeing J.B. this morning.
I'm so sad.
Oh, are you guys okay?
And last night, because he was working last night.
那是什么时候上映的？哦，我敢说20年前了。好吧。肖恩，我今天早上差点就错过见J.B.了。我好难过。哦，你们俩都还好吗？还有昨晚，因为他昨晚在工作。
He's working splits.
Now, tell Tracy what a split is, Sean.
We take a banana.
Jason. I'm in.
Jason.
A split is like when you start at noon,
and then you end at midnight.
So you can shoot some day scenes and some night scenes
他在上两段班。现在，给特雷西解释一下什么是两段班，肖恩。我们拿一根香蕉。杰森。我加入。杰森。两段班就像是你中午开始上班，然后半夜结束。所以你可以拍一些白天的戏，也可以拍一些晚上的戏，
all in the same 12 hours of work.
And it's gonna fun,
because you can avoid.
avoid, you can avoid a full night shoot, which everybody dislikes.
Yeah, it's not.
It's not.
And at our age, doing a night shoot.
Also, it's summer because so the light is, it takes a long time to get dark.
都在同一个12小时的工作时间内完成。这会很有趣，因为你可以避免。避免，你可以避免一整夜的夜戏，那是所有人都不喜欢的。对，不喜欢。不喜欢。而且以我们的年纪，拍夜戏。还有，现在是夏天，所以天光很亮，天黑得很慢。
Oh, explain that to us.
You have a short, you don't have a lot of night hours, so it's not ideal.
Sean, um, yeah, Johnny.
Hi.
How's everybody doing?
It's so good.
Sean, I haven't seen each other in a long time.
I know. I mean, I've phacimedime to you a few days ago, but it's been a minute.
哦，给我们解释一下。时间很短，你没有多少晚上的时间，所以这并不理想。肖恩，嗯，是的，强尼。嗨。大家最近怎么样？太好了。肖恩，我们好久没见了。我知道。我是说，几天前我才给你发过FaceTime，但确实有一段时间没见了。
A minute.
And Jay's working his balls on.
Yeah.
He worked them right?
I heard he worked them clear off.
Yeah.
I gelded myself yesterday.
Oh, no.
有一段时间了。而且杰伊累得要死。对。他干得对吗？我听说他累得连蛋都快掉了。对。我昨天把自己阉了。哦，不。
No.
Wait, how was the first week, J.B.?
Really, really good.
I'm very, very happy.
It was hard.
It was a lot.
It's a lot of work.
God damn.
不。等等，第一周感觉怎么样，J.B.？真的，真的很好。我非常非常开心。很难。事情很多。有很多工作。真他妈的。
Yeah, it is.
I mean, how long of the days?
Like 12 hours?
They're 12 hours.
But, like, you know, you'd like,
you raise your hand for the, you know,
the position of, like,
supposedly having the answers to everything.
对，确实。我是说，每天工作多长时间？大概12小时？是12小时。但是，就像，你知道的，你举手争取了那个……你知道的，据说对所有事情都有答案的职位，
it means you got to like try to think about everything and everybody looks at you
like what's next yeah you can't just sit in your trailer and wait for them to say okay we're done
we're ready for you come on come speak right right isn't that nice i know actors have it nice
um we i went to my niece's wedding uh laura in iowa i've never been to iowa wait a second
i've never been to iowa i know by the way there's no direct flights from los angeles to iowa so you
have to go los angeles to chicago or dallas to iowa
Anyway, on the way back, everything was canceled.
It took 12 hours to get home.
这意味着你得试着去考虑所有事情，每个人都看着你，问接下来怎么办。是的，你不能只是坐在你的房车里，等着他们说“好了，我们结束了，我们准备好了，出来说话吧”。对，对。演员的生活不是很美好吗？嗯，我们……我去了我侄女的婚礼，嗯，劳拉在爱荷华州。我从来没去过爱荷华州。等一下，我从来没去过爱荷华州。我知道，顺便说一句，从洛杉矶到爱荷华没有直飞航班，所以你必须从洛杉矶飞芝加哥或达拉斯，再去爱荷华。总之，在回来的路上，所有航班都取消了。花了12个小时才回到家。
Why?
Because you had to do some driving?
Yeah, because the weather.
Then everybody changes their seats and then we got five.
Then we're going to go to Cleveland and then that was delayed.
And then we...
Cleveland?
We got a driver to drive us because there was no cars to rent when we landed to get there.
为什么？因为你得开车？对，因为天气。然后每个人都换座位，接着我们有五个人。然后我们要去克利夫兰，接着那个也延误了。然后我们……克利夫兰？我们找了个司机开车送我们，因为我们落地时根本租不到车去那里。
And it was four hour drive.
Wait a second.
But it was worth it.
Hold on.
It was worth it.
Was it really?
Yes.
Who is this?
开了四个小时的车。等一下。但这是值得的。等一下。这是值得的。真的吗？是的。这是谁？
Who is my niece.
My niece, Laura, and her new husband, Christian.
Oh, but when's the last time you said?
saw this niece?
Last year, I think.
So once a year...
She came out to visit, right?
She came out to visit in L.A.
谁是我的侄女。我的侄女劳拉和她的新丈夫克里斯蒂安。哦，不过你上次见是什么时候？见过这个侄女？去年，我想。所以一年一次……她来探亲过，对吧？她来洛杉矶探亲过。
No, this is a different one.
I have a lot of them.
Oh, Laura's never been invited.
No, Laura's never...
She'd never gotten a nod, okay.
So you...
Anyway, that's what happened.
I know, but this whole sort of...
不，这是另一个。我有很多侄女。哦，劳拉从来没被邀请过。不，劳拉从来没……她从来没得到过认可，好吧。所以你……总之，事情就是这样。我知道，但整个这种……
How...
And then it was outside, which you would have hated.
I didn't mind it.
Really warm?
It was bugs, humid, hot, and all that, under a tent.
But it was nice.
And you're wearing a suit?
I was wearing a suit.
怎么……而且是在户外的，你肯定讨厌这样。我不介意。非常热？有虫子，又闷又热，诸如此类的，在一个帐篷底下。但还挺好的。你还穿着西装？我穿着西装。
Yeah, by the way, which I borrowed.
Do you guys ever do this?
Do you ever borrow suits from the shoot you're doing whatever job you're on?
Sure.
Yeah, so I'm doing the morning show and I'm just like, can I have this suit to where to, they're like, sure, just bring it back.
People are going to watch the show and go, hey.
Hey, there's that Iowa.
I was at a wedding.
对，顺便说一句，我是借的。你们干过这种事吗？你们有没有从你们正在拍摄的剧组或任何工作的地方借西装？当然。对，所以我正在拍《早间新闻》，我当时就想，我能把这件西装穿去……他们说，当然，穿完还回来就行。人们看节目时会想，“嘿。嘿，那是那个爱荷华州的家伙。”我在一个婚礼上。
I was at a wedding in Iowa and I think I.
But what about, I'm so fascinated with everyone's family, feeling like family obligations because it's, it's, you know, usually the family that you.
I know, here we go.
I'm laughing before we start.
The best days of the year, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Like holidays and things like that.
You kind of, you have to spend with the people you never see.
我在爱荷华州参加一个婚礼，我想我。但是，我对每个人的家庭都着迷，觉得家庭义务就像是，因为这是，你知道的，通常是你那个……我知道，开始了。我还没开始就在笑了。一年中最好的几天，对吧？对，对。就像假期之类的。你有点，你不得不和那些你从不见面的人一起度过。
You know what?
What do you mean?
I just, J.B, not only that, J.B.,
I'll take it a step further.
I just said within the last week,
I think that weddings on summer weekends should be outlawed.
Yeah.
But you're with your family.
你知道吗？你什么意思？我只是，J.B，不仅如此，J.B.，我再深入一步。我上周刚说过，我觉得夏天周末的婚礼应该被法律取缔。对。但你是在和你的家人在一起。
You get a finite amount of stuff.
summer weekends.
Why do we got, let's do me in the winter,
everybody's bummed down and got nothing to do.
But we're older.
We don't have school to go to in the fall.
What are you talking about?
Well, just for, in general, no, but the kids are off school.
你只有有限的东西。夏天的周末。我们为什么非要……让我们在冬天办吧，每个人都垂头丧气的，也没什么事可做。但我们年纪大了。到了秋天我们又不用上学。你在说什么？好吧，只是为了，总的来说，不，但孩子们放假了。
And it's a time, you know, like,
yeah, well, that's true.
But when you're talking about finite number of weekends,
talk about a rarity.
What about Christmas or, you know,
Thanksgiving.
No, no, I'm just saying, like,
you have these singular days or Thanksgiving is like a four-day weekend.
这是一个时期，你知道的，就像，是的，好吧，这倒也是。但当你谈论有限的周末数量时，这可真是个稀罕物。那圣诞节或者，你知道的，感恩节呢？不，不，我的意思是，你有这些独特的日子，或者感恩节就像一个四天的周末。
You don't want to spend those incredible moments,
with the people that you have spent
the 350-some days prior to that
four-day weekend?
You don't just want to, like...
I mean, listen, love my family and all that stuff.
And all that stuff.
I just don't want to see him at Christmas.
你不会想把那些不可思议的时刻，浪费在那些在你那四天周末之前的350多天里陪伴你的人身上吧？你不会只是想……我是说，听着，我爱我的家人和所有那些东西。和所有那些东西。我只是不想在圣诞节见到他们。
No, I just like...
I never get to see my family
because I live in Los Angeles,
everybody else is there, so it was great to be there.
Right, but why not pick some times
that are kind of off those moments to see each other?
I'm saying, let's start filling January
weekends up with weddings.
不，我只是喜欢……我从来见不到我的家人，因为我住在洛杉矶，其他人都在那儿，所以能去那儿感觉真好。对，但为什么不挑一些错开这些时刻的时间见面呢？我的意思是，让我们开始把一月份的周末排满婚礼吧。
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
By the way, you know what the food was served at the wedding?
Portillo's.
Oh, really?
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean, Sean.
对。你知道我的意思吗？顺便问一句，你知道婚礼上供应的是什么食物吗？Portillo's的热狗。哦，真的吗？哇。对。我是说，肖恩。
It was amazing.
Did you leave anybody for anybody else?
Did you do some dancing, Sean?
I did.
I don't think I've ever seen you dance.
Do you dance?
I'll dance for you.
How much you got?
太棒了。你给别人留点了吗？你跳舞了吗，肖恩？跳了。我觉得我从来没见你跳过舞。你会跳舞吗？我为你跳。你给多少钱？
No, seriously.
Do you, are you a dancer at parties?
Not really.
I mean, I was when I was young.
I didn't care.
I danced like no one was watching.
Yeah, but that was like on a pedestal, like inside a cage.
like when you walked out in the club.
不，说真的。你会，你在派对上是个舞者吗？不算吧。我是说，我年轻的时候是。我不在乎。我跳舞就像没人看着一样。对，但那就像在一个底座上，在一个笼子里。就像你走到俱乐部里一样。
Yeah, that's with a gag ball and nipple touses.
Sean and I...
That was me danced on a box.
Sean and I once had a dance off.
Yes, on the Willing Grace program.
Oh, on Willing Grace program, yeah.
Willie, I don't think I've ever seen you dance at a party either.
I was just talking about it on the way out here on the L.A.
对，那是戴着口球和乳贴。肖恩和我……那是我在箱子上跳舞。肖恩和我曾经有过一场舞蹈对决。是的，在《威尔和格蕾丝》节目上。哦，在《威尔和格蕾丝》节目上，对。威利，我觉得我也从来没见你在派对上跳舞。我刚才在出来的路上还在谈论这个，在L.A.
I will dance, and I do a lot of...
Mine's very suggestive.
Yeah, mine's really suggestive.
What does that look like?
Mine's really suggestive, and it's a lot of, like...
A lot of hands come hithery, you know what I mean.
And you kind of turn your back to your partner and just kind of arch and offer?
Yeah, I just...
我会跳舞，我做了很多……我的非常具有暗示性。对，我的真的很有暗示性。那是什么样子的？我的真的很有暗示性，而且有很多，就像……有很多招手的手势，你知道我的意思吗。然后你把背转给你的伙伴，然后有点像拱起身体并做出邀请？对，我只是……
Arch and offer.
That's the name of your biography.
That's a good name for like a bookstore or like a cafe.
Hey, you guys, I'm just going to get a coffee from arch and offer.
You can send me to want anything.
Do you guys want anything?
And it turns out it's my son Archie and my attorney Robert.
offer.
拱起身体并做出邀请。这是你传记的名字。这名字很适合书店或咖啡馆。嘿，伙计们，我要去“拱起身体与邀请”买杯咖啡。你们有什么需要的吗？你们想要点什么吗？结果发现那是我的儿子阿尔奇和我的律师罗伯特。邀请。
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
Arch and offer.
Oh, gosh.
Speaking of, I don't know how to get in it.
I can't wait to see if there's any relevance at all to Arch and Offer and your guest.
There's zero transition.
Other than I've been waiting for this and so so excited.
哦，是的。给你。拱起身体与邀请。哦，天哪。说到这个，我不知道怎么切入。我迫不及待地想看看“拱起身体与邀请”和你的嘉宾之间到底有没有任何关联。完全没有过渡。除了我一直在等待这一刻，而且超级兴奋。
And Jason kind of already tipped it maybe.
Today?
Today already.
Yeah, he already tipped who this might be or who this is.
Okay, so I'm going to guess this real fast.
My guest today grew up in Oldham, England, the son of two bank employees.
In high school, he got a D in math, but then in college went on to graduate with honors in physics,
earn a PhD, and work on the largest science experiment ever built.
而且杰森有点已经透露了也许。今天？今天已经透露了。是的，他已经透露这可能是谁或者这是谁了。好吧，那我快点猜一下。我今天的嘉宾在英格兰奥尔德姆长大，父母都是银行职员。高中时他的数学得了D，但后来在大学里以物理学荣誉学位毕业，获得了博士学位，并参与了有史以来建造的最大的科学实验。
Before all that, he played keyboards in a band that hit number one with a song
that became the soundtrack to a British Prime Minister's election victory.
He's broken the Guinness World Record for Biggest-selling Science Show four times in a row.
It's the wonderful, brilliant physicist and professor, Jay,
Brian Cox
No
Yes
Brian Cox
在此之前，他在一支乐队里弹键盘，这支乐队的一首歌曾登上榜首，并成为英国首相竞选胜利的配乐。他连续四次打破吉尼斯世界纪录，创下了最畅销科学秀的记录。他就是伟大、杰出的物理学家和教授，杰伊，布莱恩·考克斯。不。是的。布莱恩·考克斯。
No way
The other one
Hello
Isn't that crazy
It's the other one
It's we Brian Cox
Yeah
Oh Brian I've watched so many of your videos
不会吧。另一个。你好。这太疯狂了吧？是另一个。是，我们，布莱恩·考克斯。对。哦，布莱恩，我看过你太多的视频了。
And you've confused me so much
And also
I can't wait to ask you everything
I literally wrote
I have over 60 questions
Wow
Really?
Yeah
你把我弄糊涂得太厉害了。而且我也迫不及待地想问你一切。我真的写了，我有60多个问题。哇。真的吗？对。
No way
But we'll get to like four
It's very good
First of all Brian
I'm sorry that we've lowered the bar
here for you that you have to come and join us today so let me just say that right from the get-go
what is your what is your area of expertise in science so it's a particle physics and cosmology
particle physics and any question about the universe as a whole yeah any question about the universe
不会吧。但我们只会谈到四个。这非常好。首先，布莱恩，我很抱歉我们在这里把标准降低了，让你今天不得不来加入我们，所以让我从一开始就问，你在科学领域的专业领域是什么？是粒子物理学和宇宙学。粒子物理学，以及任何关于整个宇宙的问题。对，任何关于宇宙的问题。
so should i should i give him the mirror question and see if he can give me an answer on that
not yet no hold it hold it yeah we would jason was once we once had another episode where jason
was confused about light travel
The podcast, yeah.
And I forget, oh, no, it was time travel.
It was time travel.
Anyway.
Time travel.
那我应该，我应该问他那个镜子问题，看看他能不能给我一个答案吗？还没，不，等等，等等。是的，杰森曾经，我们以前有过另一期节目，杰森对光速旅行感到困惑。播客，对。我忘了，哦，不，那是时间旅行。那是时间旅行。总之。时间旅行。
We can do that.
Anyway, yeah.
Thanks for doing this.
I know you're very busy.
And like Will said, thanks for dumbing it for a day.
That's a huge pleasure.
I'm a huge fan.
So, thank you, nice.
我们可以讨论那个。总之，对。谢谢你来做客。我知道你很忙。就像威利说的，谢谢你今天把智商降下来陪我们。这真是个巨大的荣幸。我是你的超级粉丝。所以，谢谢你，太好了。
I am Starstruck.
Brian, I honestly don't know where to start.
I'm so like, exactly.
You start with a pond there with Starstruck.
I did.
I did start with that point.
So wait, before I start in everything,
because then I'm, because this will launch us into what I want to talk about.
我太崇拜了。布莱恩，我老实说不知道从哪里开始。我太……没错。你从星光熠熠的那一点开始。我确实是。我确实是从那个点开始的。所以等等，在我开始谈论所有事情之前，因为这会把我们引向我想谈的话题。
So first of all, did you really get a D in math
and if that's true,
what made you continue to explore interest
in the thing that you weren't doing well in?
I did get a D in math,
and the reason was that,
so I, as you said, grew up in Manchester,
and New Order were doing a gig at the Hassee.
所以首先，你数学真的得过D吗？如果那是真的，是什么让你继续探索你并不擅长的领域的兴趣？我数学确实得过D，原因在于，正如你所说，我在曼彻斯特长大，新秩序乐队（New Order）要在哈西安达夜总会（The Hacienda）演出。
Wait, that's one of my favorite bands of all time.
Yeah, so they were at the Hesienda
the night before my math A-level.
And I thought, well, it's more important
to go and see New Order at the Hacienda
because I thought it was going to be a musician,
as you said.
I thought,
等等，那是我有史以来最喜欢的乐队之一。对，所以在我的数学高级水平考试（A-level）的前一晚，他们在哈西安达演出。我想，去哈西安达看新秩序乐队演出更重要，因为正如你所说，我以为我要成为一名音乐家。我以为，
and they're going to be a rock star.
This stuff doesn't matter.
So I went to see New Order instead and got a deep in Mad.
I love that.
I've never been to Manchester,
but so many of my favorite bands are from there.
And even I know about Hacienda as just this, yeah.
Yeah, this mythical place to go and see all those great bands back in the Oasis,
他们要成为摇滚巨星。这些东西根本不重要。所以我去看新秩序乐队了，结果数学得了D。我太喜欢这个了。我从来没去过曼彻斯特，但我最喜欢的很多乐队都来自那里。甚至我都听说过哈西安达，就像一个，对。对，这是一个传奇的地方，可以去观看所有那些伟大的乐队，回到绿洲乐队（Oasis），
as you say, New Order, the Smiths, everybody, right?
Like that's just stone roses.
Yeah, yeah.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then, and actually the, so Peter Saville,
who's the great designer who designed the Hacienda,
and he designed a Joy Division, Unknown Pleasures album cover,
正如你所说，新秩序乐队，史密斯乐队（The Smiths），每个人，对吧？就像那是石玫瑰乐队（The Stone Roses）。对，对。哇。对。然后，事实上，彼得·萨维尔（Peter Saville），设计哈西安达的伟大设计师，他设计了快乐分裂乐队（Joy Division）的《未知快乐》（Unknown Pleasures）专辑封面，
New Orders album covers.
So he designed the T-shirts for my tour.
You mentioned that I do these live shows.
He designed the T-shirts.
You guys, they're stadium shows.
I mean, I can't wait to go to one.
He's, yeah.
We're in L.A. actually, next year.
新秩序乐队的专辑封面。所以他为我的巡演设计了T恤。你提到过我做这些现场演出。他设计了T恤。伙计们，那是体育场级别的演出。我的意思是，我迫不及待地想去参加一个。他，对。我们在L.A.，实际上，明年。
Really?
It'll be theater, I think.
I'm going.
Wow.
Yeah.
So Peter, he's famous for not putting the name
or whatever on the album cover.
you know, very famously, the Blue Monday 12-inch,
真的吗？我想应该是剧院演出。我要去。哇。对。所以彼得，他以不在专辑封面上写名字或诸如此类的东西而闻名。你知道的，非常著名的是，《蓝色星期一》（Blue Monday）12英寸黑胶唱片，
so it cost more to produce than it sold for, you know,
and lost the money.
So he did the T-shirts, and he just wrote,
Existence, What Does It Matter?
So that's the T-shirt.
Whoa.
So it doesn't say me.
So if you'd like me to answer that, I'm welcome.
它的制作成本比卖出去的还要高，你知道的，赔了钱。所以他设计了T恤，上面只写着：“存在，这又有什么关系？”这就是那件T恤。哇。所以上面没有我的名字。如果你想让我回答那个，我很乐意。
Yeah, yeah.
So, Brian, what happens at your stadium shows?
What do you do?
They're basically big LED screens as much as we can get in.
So, you know, 100 foot across kind of.
LED. And the current show, I just got back yesterday, actually, from Australia, New Zealand,
Singapore, where we'd done some shows. And I basically start with the beginning of science.
I talk about life in the universe, the origin of the universe, the evolution of the universe,
对，对。所以，布莱恩，你的体育场演出都有些什么内容？你都做些什么？基本上就是尽可能大的LED屏幕。所以，你知道，大约100英尺宽的LED。目前的演出，我实际上昨天刚从澳大利亚、新西兰、新加坡回来，我们在那里做了一些演出。我基本上从科学的起源开始讲起。我谈论宇宙中的生命、宇宙的起源、宇宙的演化，
and the future of the universe, and discuss the Fermi paradox, the great silence.
Pretty much everything, actually, and the meaning of existence.
Oh, my God, I want it all. I know. That's my idea. Yeah.
No.
Let me just ask you right off the bat, why?
Why is there a universe or why do the show?
Yeah, well, you can start there.
We can start there.
以及宇宙的未来，并讨论费米悖论、伟大的寂静。几乎所有事情，实际上，还有存在的意义。哦，天哪，我全都要。我知道。这就是我的想法。对。不。让我直截了当地问你，为什么？为什么会有宇宙？或者为什么要办这个节目？对，你可以从那开始。我们可以从那开始。
Simply why.
It's a good question, right?
So we don't even know if the universe had a beginning.
But what about the Big Bang theory?
So we know there was a Big Bang, which is that we know that the universe was hot and dense 13.8 billion years ago.
Yeah.
But whether that was an origin in time or whether that was something that happened in a pre-existing universe that could be eternal, we don't know.
We don't even know what time is, actually.
简单地问为什么。这是个好问题，对吧？所以我们甚至不知道宇宙是否有过开始。但是大爆炸理论呢？所以我们知道曾经有过大爆炸，也就是说我们知道138亿年前宇宙是炽热而致密的。对。但那究竟是时间上的一个起，源，还是发生在某个可能永恒的先前存在的宇宙中的事情，我们并不知道。实际上，我们甚至不知道时间是什么。
Right.
So it's very difficult to speak about a beginning.
So the answer, the question why, well, it's a question to you really.
Does that, if the universe is infinite and has always existed, is it possible to ask the question why?
Yeah, yeah.
We got to take a break.
Brian, Brian, sorry, I just got to go empty my brain.
But also the concept of like, what is the universe in?
对。所以谈论一个开始是非常困难的。所以答案，关于为什么的问题，嗯，这其实是个问题抛给你。如果宇宙是无限的且一直存在，那么提出“为什么”这个问题可能吗？对，对。我们得休息一下。布莱恩，布莱恩，抱歉，我得去清空一下我的大脑。还有那种概念，就是宇宙是在什么里面的？
You just can keep going back, back, back and back.
At some point, you need to find something that contains all of it.
And what is that boundary?
There isn't anything.
Jason, I would suspect, J.B., though, that that's something that we think that it needs to contain,
that we can't possibly conceive of the idea
of it not being contained.
Because we want to form,
你总是可以不断地往回追溯，回溯，再回溯。在某个时刻，你需要找到一个包含这一切的东西。那个边界是什么？什么都没有。杰森，不过我猜，J.B.，那是我们认为它需要包含的东西，我们根本无法想象它不被包含的概念。因为我们想要形成，
our brains want to make a formality.
There are boundaries to everything, yeah.
Yeah, because according to Einstein,
it's space, time, so space and time,
they don't exist in anything.
You know, there isn't like a container that contains,
it's like saying space, right?
So like the room that you're in,
我们的大脑想要建立一种形式。万物皆有边界，对吧？对，因为根据爱因斯坦的理论，那是时空，所以空间和时间，它们并不存在于任何事物之中。你知道，没有什么容器能包含它们，这就像在说空间，对吧？就像你所在的这个房间，
you don't imagine there must be a container
that contains space.
Yeah, yeah.
But time definitely exists,
Because we can all agree that this interview started in the past and the end of the interview
is going to exist in the future.
And so, sort of by definition, that contains time there, right?
That's good.
你不会想象一定存在一个包含空间的容器。对，对。但时间绝对是存在的，因为我们都可以同意这次采访开始于过去，而采访的结束将存在于未来。因此，从某种意义上说，这就包含了时间，对吧？这很好。
It's one of the deep questions, actually.
So there are ideas now from the study of black holes that suggest that space and time
emerge from something deeper.
So we're even starting to talk about building blocks of space and time.
It's an emerge by, it means something like...
Well, talk about the arrow of time.
Hang on, hang on, what does that mean the building by...
So what is that coming from?
这其实是深刻的问题之一。所以现在从黑洞研究中产生了一些想法，表明空间和时间是从更深层的事物中涌现出来的。所以我们甚至开始讨论空间和时间的构建块。这是一种涌现，意味着类似于……嗯，谈谈时间之箭。等等，等等，构建块是什么意思……所以那是从哪里来的？
Well, if you think of emerge...
An example of something that emerges is consciousness, right?
So we say, well, consciousness.
It emerges from all these atoms in a particular pattern
that's your head or your brain.
And in the same way,
people are beginning to speculate that space and time
emerge from something,
如果你想想涌现……涌现的一个例子就是意识，对吧？所以我们说，嗯，意识。它从特定模式中的所有这些原子中涌现出来，也就是你的头部或大脑。同样地，人们开始推测空间和时间是从某种事物中涌现出来的，
some kind of building blocks.
And we don't really know what they,
well, we don't know what they are.
But until we know that,
it's difficult to talk about a beginning.
Because you're right, Jason,
that when you say time,
then you're right,
某种构建块。我们其实不知道它们是，嗯，我们不知道它们是什么。但在我们知道之前，很难谈论一个开始。因为你是对的，杰森，当你提到时间时，你说得对，
that container is a good picture,
isn't it?
If you have a beginning and an end,
it's that contains everything or brackets it.
But we don't know that.
But we also like,
we know that stuff,
happened, right?
那个容器是个很好的画面，不是吗？如果你有一个开始和一个结束，那就是包含一切或将其括起来的东西。但我们并不知道。但我们也喜欢，我们知道事情发生了，对吧？
Like I could go upstairs and
I shut this door and I know that that
happened a couple of minutes ago that I shut this
door because it's shut, right?
I have... But at the same time, I remember saying
to somebody, you know,
sort of trying to understand the conception of
just now that we actually
就像我可以上楼去，我关上了这门，我知道几分钟前我关上了这门，因为门是关着的，对吧？我有……但与此同时，我记得曾对某人说过，你知道的，试图去理解“此时此刻”的概念，我们实际上
potentially only have this moment that we're
in. And I used to always say,
you know, try to go and buy
a lotto ticket, winning
a lot of ticket from yesterday. You can't.
Right? It's already happened.
And therefore, in a lot of sense, it does not exist.
It doesn't exist anywhere yesterday, right?
可能只拥有我们所在的这一刻。我过去常说，你知道的，去买一张昨天的彩票，一张昨天的中奖彩票。你买不到。对吧？它已经发生了。因此，从很多意义上讲，它并不存在。昨天它在任何地方都不存在，对吧？
Do you know, so Einstein's picture, so relativity, back from 1905 and 1915,
there's this idea called the Block Universe, which means that every moment is still there.
It's like a map.
So you could imagine drawing a map of the world now.
So I could leave London and come and fly to Los Angeles.
you wouldn't say that London has gone.
You'd say somewhere.
So in this case, in Einstein's picture,
你知道吗，所以爱因斯坦的画卷，也就是相对论，可以追溯到1905年和1915年，有一个叫“块状宇宙”（Block Universe）的概念，这意味着每一个时刻都依然存在。它就像一张地图。所以你可以想象现在画一张世界地图。所以我可以离开伦敦，坐飞机去洛杉矶，你不会说伦敦已经消失了。你会说它在某个地方。所以在这种情况下，在爱因斯坦的画卷中，
all those moments, all your memories, all your past and your future
exist somewhere in space time.
And you just travel over the map.
That's an idea called the Block Universe.
But that sort of reminds me of like this.
I'm on the wrong, gummy.
That makes me think of that,
the concept that I still can't sort of get my head around
所有那些时刻，你所有的记忆，你所有的过去和未来都存在于时空中的某个地方。而你只是在地图上旅行。这个概念被称为块状宇宙。但这有点让我想起这个。我走错方向了，天哪。这让我想起了那个我依然无法理解的概念，
is, you know, since we've all seen these pictures
with these new powered telescopes
where we have images
of what that first separation was of the Big Bang, right?
So that is, we are looking into the past there
because presumably the Big Bang
is what started, all those rocks came out of there
and one of those rocks is the planet Earth, right?
你知道的，既然我们都看过这些照片，通过这些带有我们获得的那种第一批望远镜的新型强力望远镜，我们有了大爆炸第一次分离时的图像，对吧？所以那是，我们在那里凝视着过去，因为据推测大爆炸就是一切开始的地方，所有的岩石都是从那里飞出来的，其中一块岩石就是地球行星，对吧？
So everything that we know is our,
on that one rock.
So everything that has happened since that rock was born
is, so if we can already look back
to when that rock happened,
we've already looked way, way, way back.
So we figure if we have a less powerful telescope,
we can see less back in the past.
所以我们所知道的一切都是我们的，在那块岩石上。所以自那块岩石诞生以来发生的一切都是，如果我们已经能回溯到那块岩石诞生的时候，我们就已经往回看得很远很远了。所以我们觉得如果我们有一架威力较小的望远镜，我们就能少看一些过去。
And we could see like eventually,
if you had a really weak telescope,
you could see yesterday.
Like we already have a telescope
that can see the beginning of time
as far as Earth goes.
So all of that,
time, that's what I was trying to get at with that other scientists that we were talking about.
我们甚至可以像，最终，如果你有一架真的很弱的望远镜，你就能看到昨天。就像我们已经有了一架能看到时间开端的望远镜，就地球而言。所以所有这一切，时间，这就是我试图和我们刚才谈论的那个科学家探讨的。
If we can already see back to the beginning of when the Earth started, then we should be able to
see like four or five years ago, right?
So the way to think about it, what's happening is, so light travels one foot per nanosecond.
Or 186,000 miles per second?
Yeah, is that right?
It's one foot per nanosecond.
So if you're now one foot away from your...
computer screen, let's say,
如果我们已经能看到地球开始的起点，那么我们就应该能看到比如四五年前的事情，对吧？所以思考这个问题的方式，正在发生的是，光每纳秒传播一英尺。或者说每秒186,000英里？对，是这样吗？是每纳秒一英尺。所以如果你现在距离你的……电脑屏幕有一英尺远，比方说，
then you're seeing it one nanosecond
in the past. Right.
Exactly. So it's in that sense
that if you look at a galaxy, the most
distance one we've seen at the moment
is called Mom Z-14,
M-O-M-Z-14.
That's cute. And the light travel time
那么你看到的它就是一纳秒前的过去。对。没错。所以从这个意义上说，如果你看一个星系，我们目前看到的最远的那个叫做Mom Z-14，M-O-M-Z-14。真可爱。光传播的时间
from that is 13 and a half
billion years.
Right. So you're seeing it as it was
13 and a half billion years ago. But that's
just in the same sense.
Yeah, it would be easier to see. Yeah.
Well, like the heat we're feeling from the sun left the sun seven minutes ago.
That's how long.
从那里过来是135亿年。对。所以你看到的是它135亿年前的样子。但这只是在同样的意义上。对，那会更容易看到。嗯，就像我们从太阳感受到的热量是在七分钟前离开太阳的。这就是时间。
Eight minutes, yeah.
So it's been traveling at 186,000 miles per second for eight minutes,
and now it's finally hitting your cheek and you're feeling it.
Yeah, so you're seeing the sun as it was eight minutes.
You're looking in the past.
So shouldn't we be able to see if we really dialed in our telescopes just right?
We should be able to see what we were doing last week if you had that mirror up there.
J.B. I tell you something, Brian,
八分钟，对。所以它以每秒186,000英里的速度传播了八分钟，现在它终于撞击了你的脸颊，你感受到了。对，所以你看到的是太阳八分钟前的样子。你在凝视过去。那如果我们把望远镜调得刚刚好，我们难道不应该能看到吗？如果你把那个镜子放在那儿，我们应该能看到我们上周在做什么。J.B.我告诉你，布莱恩，
J.B. has been hung up on this for five years,
and you are going to answer him to his satisfaction.
No, you're right. If you put a mirror where the sun is,
then I guess you're right.
You'd see a reflection of the earth as it was 16 minutes ago.
Thanks for joining us today.
Holy shit is right.
That's the end of the interview.
J.B.在这个问题上纠结了五年，你今天要给他一个让他满意的答案。不，你说得对。如果你在太阳所在的地方放一面镜子，那我想你是对的。你会看到16分钟前的地球反射影像。感谢你今天加入我们。真他妈的没错。采访到此结束。
He did it. He did it. He did it.
Brian, thanks for being here.
Jay, you've got to go on tour with Brian.
I think the flaw in my math, though, is that it takes seven minutes, if we're doing the sun,
it takes seven minutes to come down to our eye and seven minutes to go back up to the mirror.
So we really could never catch up to seeing the past perfectly, I guess.
I don't know.
Well, you see, it's just in that sense that it's in exactly the same way that you're seeing your computer screen in the past.
他做到了。他做到了。他做到了。布莱恩，谢谢你来到这里。杰伊，你得和布莱恩一起去巡演。不过我想我的数学有个漏洞，那就是需要七分钟，如果我们以太阳为例，光需要七分钟到达我们的眼睛，然后再需要七分钟回到镜子上。所以我想我们永远无法真正追赶上完美地看到过去。我不知道。嗯，你看，这正是在那个意义上，它和你看到电脑屏幕是过去的情况完全一样。
Yeah.
But it's only a nanosecond.
Okay, we're going to move on from time.
All right.
Boy, I wish we'd go back in time and gather all that back.
You know what I mean?
J.B. is going to, until the day you die,
it's going to be on your tombstone.
对。但那只是一纳秒。好吧，我们要把话题从时间移开了。好吧。天哪，我希望我们能回到过去把所有那些都收回来。你知道我的意思吗？J.B.，直到你死的那天，这句话都会刻在你的墓碑上。
So if you had mirrors.
I'm just going to take with me, Jason, you're right.
He is right.
That's what I'm going to take from this.
Yeah, by the way.
He is right.
所以如果你有镜子的话。我要把它带走，杰森，你说得对。他是对的。这就是我要从中学到的东西。是的，顺便说一句。他是对的。他是对的。他是对的。
So can I talk about, go away from the cosmos first?
I can talk about science for just a bit.
And you may not know these things,
but I wrote them down because I wanted to ask you.
So at preparing for you coming on,
first of all, I'm so excited
because I've wanted me for a long time.
So this is a thought I had.
那我能先谈谈，离开宇宙的话题吗？我可以稍微谈谈科学。你可能不知道这些事情，但我把它们写下来了，因为我想问你。所以在为你的到来做准备时，首先，我非常兴奋，因为我很久以前就想见你了。所以这是我的一个想法。
This is bizarre, and it's going to take a minute to get to my question.
I'm sure I'm saying it wrong, but we started with symbols, drawings, hieroglyphics, right?
And then language and writing, probably because it was faster than drawing everything.
And then phones and texting.
And then we got tired of typing full words and went back to shorthand and emojis.
Are we kind of like weirdly heading back towards symbols just at a much faster speed?
Does that mean the endpoint of all of this is like telephalipel?
but the AI or some device where what we mean before we have to say it or type it,
这很离奇，需要花点时间才能切入我的问题。我确信我表述得不对，但我们是从符号、图画、象形文字开始的，对吧？然后是语言和文字，可能是因为这比画所有东西要快。接着是手机和发短信。然后我们厌倦了打完整的词，又回到了速记和表情符号。我们是不是有点像在以快得多的速度奇怪地倒退回符号？这是否意味着这一切的终点就像心灵感应？但人工智能或某种设备，在我们不得不说出或打出之前，我们心里的意思，
people will understand.
What is your opinion on that?
Like vibe and all that stuff.
Yeah.
That is a legitimate form of communication.
I feel like animals have that.
Yeah.
You know, like, they can start like, you know, you see how like those dogs,
人们就能理解。你对此有什么看法？就像“氛围”之类的东西。对。那是合法的沟通方式。我觉得动物就有那种能力。对。你知道，就像，你看那些狗，
they kind of like their nose to nose.
And they don't say anything like, fuck you, fuck you.
And then they start snapping into other.
It's just like a vibe.
And then they're communicating, you know, before.
I feel like they know how to talk without speaking.
That's what I'm saying.
Thoughts on vibe.
它们有点像鼻尖对着鼻尖。它们什么也不说，比如，去你的，去你的。然后它们开始互相龇牙咧嘴。这就像是一种氛围。然后它们在交流，你知道的，在……我觉得它们懂得不用说话就能交流。这就是我想说的。对“氛围”的看法。
I have absolutely no idea what that question means.
Okay, fine.
That's fine.
What about like a flock of birds?
A flock of birds.
All these birds, they turn at exactly the same time.
They're all corny.
对“氛围”的看法。我完全不知道那个问题是什么意思。好吧，没关系。那比如一群鸟呢？一群鸟。所有这些鸟，它们在完全相同的时刻转向。它们全都……
There's no like signal.
All right.
Ready, one, two, three.
Everybody go left.
Left.
No, I feel like they know how to talk without speaking.
Right.
But that might be out of your thing, Brian.
没有什么信号。好了，预备，一，二，三。大家向左。向左。不，我觉得它们懂得不用说话就能交流。对。但这可能超出了你的领域，布莱恩。
I just didn't know if you knew about like medical stuff.
and like AI stuff.
What about, show them your rash, Sean.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Let's talk about simulation theory, okay?
Because that's fascinating to me.
Well, is it real?
我只是不知道你是否了解医学方面的东西。还有人工智能方面的东西。对了，给他们看看你的皮疹，肖恩。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。我们来谈谈模拟理论，好吗？因为这对我很有吸引力。嗯，它是真的吗？
Meaning, like, are we living in a simulation?
Is any of this real?
Because if tomorrow we discover the universe
was a simulation,
what would be the first clue?
And would anything look fake?
But I've always heard talk about that
and I've never really understood
意思是，我们是生活在模拟中吗？这一切都是真的吗？因为如果我们明天发现宇宙是一个模拟程序，第一个线索会是什么？会有什么看起来是假的吗？但我一直听到人们谈论这个，却从来没有真正理解
what it means.
Like there's somebody like watching up a mission control
that this is all just sort of like a gag.
Let's see what Brian says.
Yeah, we did a radio show on this
a few years ago now.
And there's a guy called Nick Bostrom
who thinks about this quite a lot in Cambridge.
它意味着什么。就像有人在任务控制中心上方看着，这一切都只是一个恶作剧。来看看布莱恩怎么说。对，几年前我们在广播节目中讨论过这个。在剑桥有一个叫尼克·博斯特罗姆（Nick Bostrom）的人，他对这个思考得相当多。
And he managed to convince everybody
that we probably were living in a simulation.
The basic idea is just
if you think about how computers are at the moment
and how powerful they are
and virtual reality and all those things.
The question ultimately is,
in principle, if you can imagine the most powerful computer,
他成功地让所有人都相信我们可能确实生活在模拟中。基本的想法很简单，如果你想想目前的电脑有多强大，以及虚拟现实和所有这些事情。归根结底的问题是，原则上，如果你能想象出最强大的电脑，
even if it's a computer that we could only build in 100 years or a thousand years time,
is it possible in principle for the simulation to be so good that you would not notice?
That's the basic idea.
And although it sounds completely mad,
it turns out it's quite difficult to try to form an argument
that says that we're not in the simulation.
I don't think we are, but I was convinced after the end of the radio show
that that was just me saying, I don't think that we are,
即使那是我们在一百年或一千年后才能建造的电脑，原则上模拟是否能做得如此逼真，以至于你根本察觉不到？这就是基本的想法。虽然这听起来完全是疯了，但结果证明，要试图形成一个论据来证明我们不在模拟中是相当困难的。我不认为我们在，但在广播节目结束后我被说服了，那只是我在说“我不认为我们在”，
without any logical argument.
I mean, yeah.
How did that theory come about then?
What evidence was presented?
I mean, that's the thing.
There isn't any evidence.
It's just the idea that if you can you imagine,
even simulating your experience, your experience,
没有任何逻辑论据。我是说，对。那这个理论是如何产生的呢？提出了什么证据？我是说，这就是问题所在。没有任何证据。这只是一种想法，如果你能想象，甚至模拟你的经历，你的经历，
your conscious experiment.
She's mentioned in AI.
So AI is getting very powerful now.
Then there's debate about whether those things are actually conscious
or whether they could be conscious
or whether they could be considered living things.
The idea is that if a computer can run a simulation of reality,
it's so perfect that it even has, you know,
你的意识实验。她提到了人工智能。所以现在人工智能变得非常强大。然后人们争论这些东西是否真的有意识，或者它们是否可能具有意识，或者它们是否可以被视为有生命的东西。这个想法是，如果一台计算机能够运行一个现实的模拟，它是如此完美，以至于它甚至拥有，你知道的，
things that operate like human brains or AI's in it.
I mean, think of an AI, for example, actually.
You think of an AI, it's running all over the computer somewhere.
But if it becomes conscious and intelligent, and we don't know whether they can, but if it did, then it's in a computer.
Right.
It is, so the question really is, are we that, I guess, basically, are we one of those?
Well, it kind of goes to the issue of like, you know, is there a formula to a thought?
Like is there is there a mathematical equation to an idea?
像人类大脑或人工智能那样运作的东西。我是说，以人工智能为例，实际上。你想象一个人工智能，它在计算机某处的某个地方运行。但如果它变得有意识和聪明，我们不知道它们是否能做到，但如果它做到了，那它就在计算机里。对。所以真正的问题是，我们是那种，我猜，基本上，我们是其中之一吗？嗯，这有点触及到这样一个问题，你知道的，想法有公式吗？就像一个想法有数学方程式吗？
In other words, in your brain, you know, it's not like a series.
It's not like a combination.
Like in a computer, it's a combination of zeros and ones, right?
In your, like that's literally like numbers and the combination of those and all the coding of that.
Please say vibe.
And in your brain, there obviously aren't numbers in there, but it's like a series of electronic impulses and a combination of all that and some blood and all that give you an idea to, you know, for
me to ask this question. I like got the idea and then I then I spoke it. I don't think they figured out
what that mathematical formula is for that idea to ask a question or that idea to walk outside or
换句话说，在你的大脑里，你知道，它不像是一个序列。它不像是一个组合。就像在电脑里，它是零和一的组合，对吧？在你身上，就像那是字面上的数字和它们的组合以及所有的代码。请说“氛围”。而在你的大脑里，那里显然没有数字，但它是一系列电子冲动和所有这些的组合，还有一些血液等等，给了你一个想法，去，你知道的，让我问这个问题。我有了这个想法，然后我把它说出来了。我不认为他们已经弄清楚那个想法的数学公式是什么，从而能够问一个问题，或者那个想法能够走出去，或者
that they're all different equations that give you different ideas. And as soon as they figure out
what that, what that equation is, then perhaps that like in other words, how do they give
AI consciousness,
how does it become
thinking on its own
instead of just dealing with prompts?
Have you heard of Alan Turing?
Yes, of course.
它们是给你不同想法的不同方程式。一旦他们弄清楚那个，那个方程式是什么，那么也许就像，换句话说，他们如何赋予人工智能意识，它是如何开始自己思考的，而不仅仅是处理提示词？你听说过阿兰·图灵（Alan Turing）吗？听过，当然。
So Alan Turing
had an idea called a Turing machine,
a universal Turing machine.
And that was basically
the idea that all computers
that have some kind of basic
functionality are equivalent to each other.
So that they can
所以阿兰·图灵有一个叫做图灵机的概念，通用图灵机。基本意思是所有具备某种基本功能的计算机都是等效的。所以它们可以
all do the same thing. So even this thing that he imagined with a little paper tape going through
sort of this 1930s kind of picture of what a computer might be, could, if given enough time,
do everything that the computer on our desktops can do now, or everything that all the computers
that are running all the AIs and chat GBT and everything in the world, they're all equivalent
to each other. And so the question just becomes, is our brain a universal touring machine?
and many people think it is
and a few people think it isn't
I would say most people think it is
都做同样的事情。所以即使是他想象的那种有一小段纸带穿过去的、20世纪30年代对计算机可能是什么样子的那种构想，如果在给予足够时间的情况下，也能做我们现在桌面电脑能做的一切，或者做运行世界上所有人工智能、ChatGPT和所有东西的所有计算机所做的一切，它们在本质上都是等效的。所以问题就变成了，我们的大脑是一个通用图灵机吗？许多人认为是，也有少数人认为不是，我想大多数人认为是。
so all you're saying really is that a sufficiently
powerful computer
could
do precisely what you are doing now
in fact that's the idea
but we are informed by
and JB this kind of goes to it too
part of what you
所以你真正要说的只是，一台足够强大的计算机可以精确地完成你现在正在做的事情，事实上这就是这个想法。但我们是由……而且JB这也有点符合这一点，部分原因是你
inspired you to ask a question
for instance and as the example
was informed
by years of
your living on this planet, years of trauma, exhilaration, sadness, joy, all those things,
emotion.
A lot of trauma and a lot of sadness.
I know.
激发了你提出问题，举个例子，正如这个例子所示，它是由你在这个星球上生活多年的经历、多年的创伤、兴奋、悲伤、快乐，所有这些东西，情绪所塑造的。大量的创伤和大量的悲伤。我知道。
And so, right.
And then that becomes the question, like, how, those are the things that, that's the information
on an emotional level that potentially maybe AI could have, but can a computer ever
understand those, you know, the compounding, not just those emotions, but the
compounding of them in various ways.
The piling on, the stripping off, all of that stuff forms the basis of who you are and why
you woke up the way you did today.
Yes, but if you think about your brain, what is it?
所以，对吧。然后这就成了一个问题，比如说，怎么说呢，这些东西，那是情感层面的信息，人工智能可能潜在地具备，但是一台计算机能够真正理解那些，你知道的，不仅仅是那些情感，还有它们以各种方式叠加在一起的过程吗？各种压力的堆积，层层剥离，所有这些东西构成了你是谁以及你今天为什么会以那种方式醒来的基础。是的，但如果你想想你的大脑，它究竟是什么？
Then it's just a collection of atoms, which is a remarkable thing to say, actually.
Going back to what we were talking about earlier, the origin of the universe, the end point
billion years ago, there's just hydrogen and helium and the generations of stars and they build
carbon and oxygen. And those
atoms have come together in a pattern,
temporary pattern, which
is you and me.
But if your brain is just that,
然后它就只是一堆原子，这其实是一个非常了不起的说法。回到我们刚才讨论的话题，宇宙的起源，数十亿年前的终点，那里只有氢和氦，以及一代又一代的恒星，它们聚成了碳和氧。而这些原子以某种模式聚集在一起，一种暂时的模式，也就是你和我。但如果你的大脑仅仅只是那样，
and I would say it is, right?
So it's just a collection of atoms, a very
complex collection. Then
the idea is that it's
I can't conceive of anything
it could be other than a computer.
It's got a lot of data in it.
You're talking about your memories there in there.
而且我认为它就是，对吧？所以它只是一堆原子，一个非常复杂的集合体。那么我的看法是，除了是一台计算机之外，我想象不出它还能是什么别的东西。它里面有大量的数据。你刚才说到的记忆，全都在里面。
And it's processing them. So I
don't see, if you want to, if anyone wants to say, well, there's a real fundamental difference,
you have to say what it is. And I don't see that anything it could be. It's a load of atoms
in a remarkable pattern. Yeah. What are you most excited for AI to possibly accomplish? Is there
one thing you really have your fingers crossed on? I mean, it's, it's, there are enormous questions
in science. We talked about one, the origin of the universe. There's what happens inside a black hole.
We don't know about that. There are all the questions that you mentioned about biology, the way
the human brain works. To me, if AI can be powerful enough to answer those questions, if it can be
而且它正在处理这些数据。所以我不明白，如果你想，如果有人想说，好吧，这里有一个真正根本的区别，你必须说出它到底是什么。而我不觉得它还能是什么别的东西。它就是一堆排列奇特的原子。是的。对于人工智能可能取得的成就，你最期待的是什么？有没有哪一件事是你真的在拭目以待的？我是说，这，科学中存在着巨大的谜题。我们刚才谈到了一个，宇宙的起源。还有黑洞内部发生了什么。我们对此一无所知。还有你提到的所有关于生物学的问题，人脑的工作方式。对我来说，如果人工智能能够强大到足以回答这些问题，如果它能
like not only a single Einstein or Stephen Hawking, but it can be a thousand Einstein's,
which is not beyond the realm of possibility.
We could get answers to the...
But it's limited to all of the questions we've already answered, right?
You upload all of those answers
and then its ability to kind of merge and combine all of those answers
to maybe formulate a new answer to a question we haven't even asked yet.
That's a possibility, right?
不仅仅是一个爱因斯坦或史蒂芬·霍金，而是能成为一千个爱因斯坦，这并非完全不可能。我们就能得到……但它仅限于我们已经解答的所有问题，对吧？你上传了所有这些答案，然后它利用自身将所有这些答案进行融合和组合的能力，或许能为一个我们甚至还没问过的问题拼凑出一个全新的答案。那是有可能的，对吧？
I read the other day, I can't remember who said it,
but I said, imagine that you could restrict it.
So it only knew stuff to, let's say, 1904, right?
So it only knew the whole data.
The only data it could have is to 1904.
Would it invent Einstein's theory of relativity?
Interesting.
She published in 1905.
我前几天看到，记不清是谁说的了，但大意是，想象一下你可以对它进行限制。所以它只知道……比方说，到1904年为止的知识，对吧？所以它只知道全部的数据。它能拥有的全部数据只到1904年为止。它能发明出爱因斯坦的相对论吗？有趣的是。她是在1905年发表的。
That is an experiment you could actually do.
Would it be able to predict all of this since 1904, even in a bigger sense?
That's a question about free will, isn't it?
another day.
Yeah, exactly.
Brian, what was the,
as you started,
as you began your sort of study
这确实是一个你可以去做的实验。它能预测1904年以来的所有这些事情吗，甚至在一个更大的层面上？这是一个关于自由意志的问题，对吧？改天再聊。对，没错。布莱恩，当你刚开始，当你开始进行某种研究
and got into your field,
was there,
when you were a younger man,
was there one big question or idea
that really captured your imagination
that took you in this direction?
Was there one thought?
Do you remember having a moment like that?
并进入你的领域时，当你还是个年轻人的时候，有没有哪个重大的问题或想法真正抓住了你的想象力，把你带向了这个方向？有没有那么一个瞬间的念头？你还记得有过这样的时刻吗？
Yeah, one of them,
and I still have it, the question,
is, is their life beyond earth
in the soul?
system?
Yeah.
Is there life beyond Earth in the Milky Way galaxy?
Uh-huh.
是的，其中之一，而且我至今仍这么觉得，那个问题是，太阳系中是否存在地球之外的生命？系统？是的。银河系中是否存在地球之外的生命？呃——哼。
I hesitate to say the universe because there are two trillion galaxies in the observable
universe, each with hundreds of billions of stars.
And so it's kind of...
Observable is the key there.
Sorry, sorry.
Yeah.
It's a good...
I was careful with my language because we don't know whether it's infinite.
我 hesitant 说是宇宙，因为在可观测宇宙中有两万亿个银河系，每个银河系都有数千亿颗恒星。所以这有点……“可观测”是其中的关键所在。抱歉，抱歉。是的。这是一个好……我在用词上很小心，因为我们不知道它是否是无限的。
And a lot of people don't...
A lot of people don't know that when you say galaxies, right, is...
So the Milky Way is a galaxy, and in the galaxy is our solar system,
and how many solar system in each galaxy-ish?
Yeah, so the Milky Way, 400 billion stars, so 400,000 million suns,
just in our one galaxy.
I mean, it's mind-law.
Yeah, in our island is stars.
很多人不知道……很多人不知道，当你提到星系时，对吧，是……所以银河系是一个星系，星系里面有我们的太阳系，那么每个星系大概有多少个太阳系？对，银河系有4000亿颗恒星，所以有4000亿个太阳，仅仅在我们这一个星系里。我的意思是，这太让人震撼了。是的，在我们的这片星系里全都是恒星。
Right, so we look up in the sky, those little white dots up there,
each one of those is a sun, right?
Those are stars, that's a sun, right?
Yeah.
They're not planets.
Well, they could be planets, yeah, because they give off light.
actually think that virtually all of them will have planets, which is a beautiful thing in itself,
actually. The other answer to your question was that it was astronomy that really captured
对，所以我们抬头看天空，天空中那些小白点，每一个都是太阳，对吧？那些是恒星，那是一个太阳，对吧？是的。它们不是行星。嗯，它们可能是行星，对吧，因为它们会发光。我其实认为基本上所有恒星都会拥有行星，这本身就是一件非常美好的事。你问题的另一个答案是，真正吸引我的是天文学。
my imagination. And when you think about it, when I was growing up in the 70s, we haven't
discovered any planets beyond the solar system, beyond our solar system. In the starting in the 1990s,
we're discovering them. So what that means is you go outside tonight when you've listened to this
and you look at the night sky and if you see the stars, all of them will have planets around
them. So solar systems, every one of those points are light. And that's one of the things that
I think is so the most beautiful thing about astronomy is then your imagination can wander. You can
look at any of those points of light and say what do those worlds look like? Are they ocean
world? Right. But sometimes they say when you look up in the sky, one of the white dots is like
想象一下，当我70年代长大时，我们还没有发现太阳系之外、我们太阳系之外的任何行星。从20世纪90年代开始，我们才开始发现它们。这意味着今天晚上你听完这个节目后走出去，抬头看夜空，如果你看到了星星，它们周围其实都拥有行星。所以每一个亮点都是一个太阳系。这就是我认为天文学最美丽的地方之一，然后你的想象力就可以驰骋了。你可以看着任何一个光点，然后说这些世界是什么样子的？它们是海洋世界吗？对。但有时人们说，当你抬头看天空时，其中一个小白点就像是
Jupiter or Mars sometimes has like a little, but they look exactly like all the other little white dots
which are suns as well, right?
Like our sun is a star.
The Earth is not a star, correct?
The Earth is a planet.
But I wonder, like, so then planets.
Why do we call them stars?
Yeah, but why do they look white as well?
木星或火星，有时会带着一点微光，但它们看起来和其他所有小小白点——也就是太阳——完全一样，对吧？就像我们的太阳是一颗恒星一样。地球不是恒星，对吧？地球是一颗行星。但我在想，既然这样，那行星……我们为什么管它们叫星星？是的，但为什么它们看起来也是白色的呢？
Because they're not emitting light.
So it's a good question.
I think that also influences also diminish stars too
because there used to be real stars and now it's just...
Right, legitimate stars.
Legitimate stars.
The big movie stars.
Sorry.
因为它们本身不发光。所以这是一个好问题。我觉得这也贬低了真正的大明星，因为以前有真正的明星，而现在只是……对，合法的明星。真正的明星。那些大电影明星。抱歉。
So, yeah, the planets,
solar system you're right so you can see Jupiter Venus is often very bright in the morning or
evening sky you'll see Mars Saturn um so those are just reflecting the light of the sun okay so that's
why you see them they don't emit their own light but they but they often look like exactly like
like like like other suns slash stars yeah although you know you get a really small telescope or
and you look at them and then you will see even with a small telescope you'll see the clouds of
Jupiter, you'll see the rings of Saturn with a small telescope.
So they're nearby and they're just reflecting the sun's light.
所以，是的，行星，太阳系，你说得对，所以你可以看到木星，金星经常在早晨或傍晚的天空中非常耀眼，你会看到火星、土星……所以这些只是反射了太阳的光，好吧，这就是为什么你能看到它们，它们不自己发光，但它们经常看起来完全就像其他太阳/恒星一样，是的，尽管你知道，如果你拿一个非常小的望远镜去看它们，哪怕是用小望远镜，你也能看到木星的云层，看到土星的光环。所以它们离得很近，只是在反射太阳的光。
We are every other thing that isn't a planet, every other point of light.
So the overwhelming majority of them are the stars.
By the way, I had, maybe I talked about this once, I had somebody say to me once,
trying to understand the infinite or the vastness of the universe and the potential infinite nature of it.
He said, imagine a library.
And in that library was a book on every imaginable subject, right?
Even a book about me describing this on this podcast,
a book about your thinking about me talking,
我们看到的其他所有不是行星的东西，每一个其他的亮点。所以其中绝大多数都是恒星。顺便说一句，我曾有过——也许我曾经说过一次，有人曾对我说过，为了理解无限或宇宙的浩瀚以及它潜在的无限本质。他说，想象一下有一个图书馆。那个图书馆里有一本关于你能想象到的每一个主题的书，对吧？甚至还有一本书讲的是我在这期播客中描述这件事情，一本书讲的是你在思考我谈论
asking this question on this podcast,
every possible subject, right,
about my relationship to the door that I talked about closing and in books.
And then imagine libraries, right,
that like that,
stacked in every direction going off
forever.
And I was like, fuck, man,
在这期播客中提出这个问题，涵盖每一个可能的主题，对吧，关于我和我刚才提到关上的那扇门之间的关系的书。然后想象一下无数个这样的图书馆，对吧，像那样，朝着各个方向堆叠，永远延伸下去。当时我就想，操，老兄，
that blew my brain out.
Well, what was that?
I can't even imagine,
as Sean said,
a single galaxy, the Milky Way.
I mean, 400,000 million stars.
It takes light 100,000 years
to cross the Milky Way.
我的大脑直接炸裂了。好吧，那是什幺？正如肖恩所说，我甚至无法想象仅仅一个银河系——也就是银河系。我是说，4000亿颗恒星。光需要100年的时间才能穿过银河系。
It's not possible to imagine.
It takes light 100,000 years.
Light years.
Light years to cross the Milky Way.
100,000 years.
Yeah.
Traveling at that speed.
At the speed of light.
这根本无法想象。光需要10万年的时间。光年。光年才能穿过银河系。10万年。是的。以那个速度旅行。以光速。
And that's just one galaxy.
Yeah.
So I have...
Guys, I'm out.
No, that's it for me.
If there's this...
You know, we talk about the supermassive black hole
at the center of our galaxy, right?
而这仅仅是一个银河系。是的。所以我有……伙计们，我不行了。不，对我来说就到这里了。如果有这个……你知道的，我们讨论过银河系中心的超大质量黑洞，对吧？
Wow.
And that's swallowing up everything, right?
Everything is going in it.
So why...
No, it's just, everything's just going around it.
Oh, around it.
It's not sucking it in.
Don't black holes suck it all in?
哇。那东西在吞噬一切，对吧？一切都在往里掉。所以为什么……不，不是的，一切只是在绕着它转。哦，绕着它转。它没有把东西吸进去吗？黑洞不都是把所有东西都吸进去的吗？
No, if you turn the sun into a black hole.
Yeah.
Now, by the way, it would be only about two miles in radius if you did that.
So it'd be really small.
But everything just carries on going around.
So the earth would just carry on going around the black hole.
Oh, I thought black holes suck everything like the light and everything around it.
Okay.
不，如果你把太阳变成一个黑洞。是的。顺便说一句，如果你这么做，它的半径大概只有两英里左右。所以它会非常小。但所有的东西都只是继续绕着它转。所以地球也只会继续绕着黑洞转。哦，我还以为黑洞会把周围的光和所有东西都吸进去呢。好吧。
So I'm going to do like, I'm going to do what is it called, rapid fire, right?
Right.
Will we ever figure out how to travel faster than light?
Or is that just, no?
No.
Okay.
I'm going to confidently say no.
Really?
所以我要做个类似……我要玩个所谓的“快问快答”，对吧？对。我们有没有可能弄清楚如何以超光速旅行？还是说那根本不可能，没门？没门。好吧。我可以自信地说，不可能。真的吗？
Will we ever be able to travel at the speed of light?
No.
So as far as we know, this is Einstein.
It's been known for 100 years.
You can't travel.
If you've got any mass at all, unless you're light, which has no mass.
You can get really as close as you want to the speed of light,
but you can't travel at it or faster than it.
我们以后能以光速旅行吗？不能。据我们所知，这是爱因斯坦的理论。这一理论已经存在100年了。你无法以那个速度旅行。如果你有任何质量，除非你是光，光是没有质量的。你可以尽可能无限接近光速，但你无法以光速或超光速旅行。
And that's as far as we know.
But we can travel faster than the speed of sound.
We've done that.
So I wonder then what is the limit of the speed that the body can travel at?
I mean, like, will our matter start to break up?
Because all of our atoms somehow stay together.
I wonder if you travel at too many Gs or whatever,
does the skin start to fall apart?
就我们目前所知，事实就是这样。但我们可以以超音速旅行。我们已经做到这一点了。所以我在想，人类身体所能承受的速度极限究竟是什么？我是说，我们的物质会开始瓦解吗？因为我们所有的原子都以某种方式黏合在一起。我在想，如果你承受的G力太大或者怎样，皮肤会开始脱落吗？
This is a great question.
So there's two things.
There's acceleration.
You said G's, you know, and that's right.
You know, anyone who's, if anyone's been lucky enough to be in a fighter plane
or something like that and gone at 7G or 8G, you know, it hurts.
Yeah.
这是一个很好的问题。所以这里有两件事。一个是加速度。是加速度。你刚才提到了G力，对吧，那是对的。你知道，如果有人足够幸运，坐过战斗机之类的飞行器，经历过7G或8G的过载，你知道，那真的很痛苦。是的。
So that's acceleration.
But speed, you can travel at any speed that you want.
And a good example,
this is what,
so the example is if you're on a plane, right?
If you're on an aircraft,
it feels like you're not moving.
Right.
所以那是加速度。但至于速度，你可以以你想要的任何速度旅行。一个很好的例子，这个例子是，如果你在一架飞机上，对吧？如果你在一架飞行器上，你会感觉你好像没在动。对。
So it might be going at 500 miles an hour
or whatever it is, but you can't tell.
And we're all traveling at about 1,000 miles an hour anyway
because the planet is spinning at about 1,000 miles an hour, right?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
It's 24 hours to make a full rotation,
and it's about a 25,000 mile around Earth.
所以它可能正以每小时500英里的速度飞行，或者无论什么速度，但你感觉不到。而且不管怎样，我们所有人都在以大约每小时1000英里的速度移动，因为地球正以大约每小时1000英里的速度自转，对吧？是这样吗？是的。地球自转一圈需要24小时，赤道周长大约是25,000英里。
What would happen if the Earth stopped spinning right now?
We'd hit the wall.
Yeah, because you'd accelerate.
It would be the end of everything, right?
Well, if it just stopped, if it slowed down gradually,
then you'd be stuck in night or day or whatever it is.
Right.
But you wouldn't, if it just suddenly stopped,
如果地球现在突然停止自转会发生什么？我们会撞到墙上。是的，因为你会产生加速度。一切都将终结，对吧？嗯，如果它只是停下来，如果它逐渐减速，那么你就会一直停留在黑夜或白天，或者无论当时是什么时候。对。但如果你不会，如果它突然停下来，
then we'd, yeah, we'd accelerate and you'd get thrown against the wall.
So we're spinning, let's say we're spinning from left to right
a thousand miles an hour, and if you get on a plane and the plane only goes 500 miles an hour,
and you're also going left to right on the plane, in theory, you'd never reach your destination.
In fact, the earth would be spinning twice the speed that you're traveling, so your destination
would actually come up behind you, and then you just sort of settle back down again,
you'd finally get there.
But the reason that we're all sort of traveling at the, you feel the 500 miles an hour,
那么我们会，是的，我们会产生加速度，然后你会被甩到墙上。所以我们在自转，假设我们正在以每小时1000英里的速度从左向右自转，如果你上一架飞机，而飞机只以每小时500英里的速度飞行，并且你在飞机上也正朝着从左向右的方向移动，理论上讲，你永远也到达不了目的地。事实上，地球自转的速度会是你飞行速度的两倍，所以你的目的地实际上会从你身后迎上来，然后你才会慢慢安顿下来，最终到达那里。但我们之所以都以这种速度旅行，你能感觉到每小时500英里的速度，
you get progress in the traveling that direction is because everything within three miles, right,
Isn't it that the atmospheric sort of bubble around the earth,
that as long as you stay only three miles off the planet,
no higher than that, you're traveling in relatively the same speed.
And that's what enables our spacecrafts to whatever speed they're traveling
when they leave that atmosphere,
they can shut off their engines and maintain that speed
because there's no gravity up there.
你在那个方向上的旅行取得了进展，是因为在三英里以内的所有东西，对吧？难道不是地球周围的大气层气泡吗，只要你保持在距离地面仅仅三英里以内的高度，不高过这个高度，你的移动速度就是相对相同的。这就是为什么我们的宇宙飞船在离开大气层时，无论以什么速度飞行，都能够关闭发动机并保持这个速度，因为上面没有引力。
Is that right?
No, there's gravity.
There's no air.
So there's no friction.
Oh, right.
So they just carry on going at whatever speed.
they're going at.
And they don't run out of fuel.
是这样吗？不对，有引力。那里没有空气。所以没有摩擦力。哦，对。所以它们会以它们当时的速度继续前进。而且它们的燃料不会耗尽。
There's loads of gravity.
Right.
And Superman used to go again.
He'd go the opposite way.
Remember?
He made the Earth turn the other way.
Well, he'd go back in time.
Yeah, they got that wrong.
有大量的引力。对。而超人以前总是反着来。他会朝相反方向飞。记得吗？他让地球反方向旋转了。嗯，他那是为了回到过去。是的，他们漫画里搞错了。
Yeah, they got that wrong in the comic book?
It's not a documentary.
Wait a second.
Oh, wow.
Okay, so what, okay, wait, I got it.
So wait, oh, we talked about the universe expanding.
my mind. I read this like, if
对，他们在漫画里搞错了？它又不是纪录片。等一下。哦，哇。等一下。好吧，所以什么，好吧，等一下，我明白了。所以等一下，哦，我们刚才讨论了宇宙膨胀。我的天哪。我读到过这样的说法，如果
the universe is expanding at this incredible
speed very, very, very
far in the future, will it be
probably
it'll probably be a real fact
that who's ever living on a planet like Earth
we won't be able to see anything else
so we won't even know anything else exists
宇宙正以这种惊人的速度膨胀，在非常非常遥远的未来，很可能会出现这样的现实：无论谁生活在像地球这样的行星上，我们将无法看到任何其他东西，所以我们甚至不会知道其他任何东西的存在，
will just see darkness. Yeah, that's
right. So all the galaxies
beyond... We'll be so far apart that we won't even be able to see
them. Wait, because of why?
Because the universe is still expanding.
It's expanding and expanding faster and faster.
Well, why won't our stars stay with us as we're expanding?
Because they're moving away from us.
我们只会看到一片黑暗。是的，那是对的。所以所有那些超越……我们将相距如此遥远，以至于我们甚至无法看到它们。等等，为什么？因为宇宙仍在膨胀。它在膨胀，而且越膨胀越快。那为什么我们的恒星不会随着我们的膨胀而和我们在一起呢？因为它们在远离我们。
But why aren't the stars expanding,
why aren't they in the same expansion as the planets are?
That's a great question as well.
That's four.
You are doing well.
Jeez.
That's four.
It's the distant galaxies that go away.
但为什么恒星没有在膨胀，为什么它们没有经历和行星相同的膨胀呢？这也是一个极好的问题。这是第四个了。你做得很好。天哪。这是第四个了。是遥远的星系在离我们而去。
So they disappear beyond what's called the horizon.
It's amazing.
But the gravity in our galaxy
keeps our galaxy together.
So we don't think the universe is going to expand
in such a way that rips everything apart.
It could do that there are ideas
where it could do in the real distant future.
所以它们消失在所谓的“视界”之外。这太神奇了。但我们星系内部的引力把我们的星系维系在了一起。所以我们认为宇宙不会以那种把一切都撕裂的方式膨胀。在非常遥远的未来，确实存在这种可能性的理论。
But we don't think that's what's happening.
Okay, so aliens.
First you said that they might,
you used to be a believer, and now you're not so much.
Is that fair to say?
No, I can't believe it took you this long to get to aliens.
If I'm being honest.
I have 12 questions on aliens.
但我们认为目前发生的不是那样。好吧，那么外星人。你首先说他们可能会存在，你以前是个相信者，但现在没那么确信了。这样说公平吗？不，我简直不敢相信你花了这么长时间才聊到外星人。如果我说实话的话。我关于外星人有12个问题呢。
It depends what you mean, right?
Because we're looking for and getting,
we haven't got absolute evidence yet,
but we're getting more and more circumstantial evidence
that there might be life on Mars.
Right, microbes, though, microbes.
Yeah, but what about, I thought you were going to say
all the photo and video evidence that's come from.
这取决于你指的是什么，对吧？因为我们正在寻找，并且正在获得——我们虽然还没有绝对的证据，但我们正在获得越来越多关于火星上可能存在生命的间接证据。对，微生物，不过是微生物。对，但是，等等，我还以为你要说那些来自……的照片和视频证据呢。
Oh, no, no, no, no, I'll get to that.
But so microbes, I would not be surprised if they're on Mars,
if they're on Jupiter's moon, or Opa,
places where there are oceans in the solar system,
and there's several moons where we think there are oceans
below the surface. So that'd be microbes. Complex life. So I'll give you one idea that if you look at
the history of life on Earth, then we know that life began around 3.8 to 4 billion years ago.
So it's pretty much as soon as the Earth had formed, then you see microbes on it. Let's say
哦，不，不，不，不，我会聊到那个的。但说到微生物，如果它们存在于火星上，存在于木星的卫星欧罗巴上——太阳系中我们认为地表以下存在海洋的几颗卫星上——我一点也不会感到意外。所以那是微生物。复杂生命。那我给你讲个观点：如果你回顾地球上生命的历史，我们知道生命大约在38亿到40亿年前就开始了。所以基本上地球刚一形成，你就在上面看到了微生物。假设在
4 billion years ago. But you see nothing more complex than a single cell back beyond about a billion
years ago. So three billion years of the four billion years of life on Earth was single cells,
just slime, basically. It's only the last sort of little four. Three, for the first three billion years.
That's how long it took for us to get where we are. So it took four billion years to go from
the origin of life to us on this planet, that which is one third of the age of the entire universe.
So many people, and I would put myself in this camp,
if you had said guess how many civilizations are there in a galaxy like the Milky Way,
I'd say, on average, less than one, which is a guess.
40亿年前。但在大约10亿年之前，你根本看不到比单细胞更复杂的东西。所以地球上40亿年生命史中的30亿年都只是单细胞，基本上就是黏液。只有最后那短短的四分之一。30亿年，前30亿年都是如此。这就是我们走到今天这一步所花费的时间。所以从生命的起源演化到我们这个星球上的人类，花了40亿年的时间，这已经是整个宇宙年龄的三分之一了。所以许多人，我也把自己归入这一阵营，如果你让我猜猜像银河系这样的星系里有多少个文明，我会说，平均下来，少于一个，这只是一个猜测。
But it's a guess based on what the only observation that we have.
We've got two observations, right?
One is we haven't seen anything.
So an astronomer's called that the Great Silence, and we could talk about that.
It's kind of a surprise.
I'll talk about that in a sec.
But so that's one observation.
And the other one is it took four billion years for us to evolve.
但这并非凭空猜测，而是基于我们仅有的观测结果。我们有两个观测结果，对吧？一个是，我们什么也没看见。所以天文学家把这称为“伟大寂静”，我们可以聊聊这个。这有点令人惊讶。我一会儿再聊这个。所以这是一个观测结果。另一个观测结果是，我们进化花了40亿年。
Right.
Now, many stars don't live for four billion years.
So what we're saying is this little planet, Earth, remained safe and stable enough
to support an unbroken chain of life for one third of the age of the universe,
which is what it took to produce us.
Wow.
And when you do it like that, even though there are hundreds of billions of place,
planets in the Milky Way galaxy. But I often say that people say, well, surely there must be
好了。现在，许多恒星的寿命根本没有40亿年。所以我们要说的是，这个名为地球的小行星，保持了足够安全和稳定的状态，支撑了一个长达宇宙年龄三分之一的不间断生命链条，而这正是孕育我们所需要的时间。哇。当你这样想的时候，尽管银河系中有数千亿个地方、
loads of civilizations, but a very big number multiplied by a very small number, which is
the chances that things are, is not necessarily a big number, right? A really big number
multiplied by a really small number can actually be a really small number. So that's the first thing.
The other thing I would say that the other bit of evidence that I'm really persuaded by is something
call the Fermi paradox.
Yeah, what is that?
Which is that imagine, so we've seen that today as we're speaking, right, SpaceX
have just done their thing on the stock market and all those things.
行星。但我经常说，人们会说，嗯，肯定会有大量的文明，但是一个非常大的数字乘以一个非常小的数字——也就是概率，并不一定是一个大数字，对吧？一个非常大的数字乘以一个非常小的数字，实际上可能是一个非常小的数字。所以这是第一点。我要说的第二点是，另一个真正说服我的证据被称为“费米悖论”。是的，那是什么？那就是，想象一下——我们今天在说话时已经看到了，对吧，SpaceX刚刚在股市上完成了他们的壮举以及所有这些事情。
And so, you know, we're building rockets.
We have two spacecraft that are in interstellar space that we're still in touch with,
the voyages spacecraft after 50 years in space.
Yeah, are we still getting information from that?
We are, yeah.
And they're in interstellar space.
So in about, most people would say modern science,
has been around for about 400 years, right, give our take, from Galileo and people like that.
所以，你知道，我们在建造火箭。我们有两艘飞船正处于星际空间，而且我们仍然与它们保持着联系，在太空中飞行了50年的旅行者号宇宙飞船。是的，我们还能从那上面获取信息吗？是的，我们能。它们在星际空间中。所以在大约——大多数人会说，现代科学已经存在了大约400年，对吧，差不多，从伽利略他们那一代人算起。
So in 400 years, we've gone from basically inventing modern science to building interstellar
spacecraft.
So imagine what we would look like in the Milky Way galaxy if you let us have another thousand years.
Or actually, let us have another million years at this rate of progress.
We haven't been around our species for that long, but give us another million years.
Imagine what we would look like.
Surely we would have gone out to the stars and anyone,
else in the Milky Way galaxy would see us. We'd have written the evidence of our existence across
所以在400年的时间里，我们基本上从发明现代科学跨越到了建造星际飞船。所以想象一下，如果你再给我们一千年时间，我们在银河系中会是什么样子。或者实际上，以这种发展速度再给我们一百万年。我们这个物种存在的时间还没那么长，但再给我们一百万年。想象一下我们会是什么样子。我们肯定已经走到了群星之中，银河系中的任何其他人都会看到我们。我们会在天空中写下我们存在的证据，
the sky. But we've seen no evidence that any civilization has done that in the 13 billion year history
of the Milky Way galaxy. So that's the Fermi paradox. But what if those folks out there
don't look like us and in fact have figured out a way to separate themselves into such small matter
and are able to travel in that small matter
such that we can't see it
in the same way that all the information on your phone
is traveling in and around us,
we can't see it.
但我们在银河系130亿年的历史中，没有看到任何文明这样做的证据。这就是费米悖论。但如果外面的那些家伙长得跟我们不一样，事实上他们已经找到了某种方法，把自己分解成极小的物质，并且能够以那种极小的物质形式旅行，以至于我们看不见它，就像你手机上的所有信息都在我们身上及周围穿梭，而我们却看不见它一样？
Like that incoming phone call
that's coming to your phone right now?
On the satellite?
No, no, just like if you called me right now,
whatever those little particles are
that lights up my phone
and makes it go ring, ring, ring,
I don't see that traveling
就像现在正打进你手机的那通电话一样？通过卫星？不，不，不，就像如果你现在打电话给我，无论是哪种微小粒子照亮了我的手机并让它发出叮铃铃的响声，我都看不到那个过程在移动，
and I don't see it going into my phone.
And so, like, maybe they figured out
how to just, like, be,
really tiny and come back together and form a body with those almond eyes when they want to.
But at other times, they're just, they're zapping around as quick and as, yeah.
J.B. J.B., didn't we talk to that guy, that idea of them living, what we were considered to be.
That was his suggestion. His suggestion is that they do exist. They are, they are here.
They just exist in a space that we can't see, much like your radio frequencies.
我也看不到它进入我的手机。所以，也许他们已经弄清楚了如何变得非常微小，然后在需要的时候重新聚集并用那些杏仁状的眼睛组成一个身体。但在其他时候，他们只是以极快的速度、以……四处穿梭。J.B.，J.B.，我们不是跟那个人聊过吗，关于他们生活在……我们所认为的那种状态下的想法？那是他的建议。他的建议是他们确实存在。他们就在这里。他们只是生活在我们看不见的空间里，非常像你的无线电频率。
But even, even, it's a, it's a very good point. And it could be.
Let's just really simply
Imagine that the little spaceships are as big as their phone
Like you said, it could be
That they've got little spaceships all over the place
They're as big as a phone
They're orbiting around the earth
We wouldn't see them
但即便如此，这是一个非常好的观点。这完全有可能。让我们非常简单地想象一下，那些小型飞船和他们的手机一样大。就像你说的，他们可能在各地都有小型飞船。它们和一个手机一样大。它们正在围绕地球运行。我们根本看不到它们。
That is a possibility
Right
There are ways out of the Fermi paradox
All we can say
Is that we've kind of looked
We have this thing called SETI
The Search for Extraterrestrial Intelligence
And we use radio telescopes
这确实是一种可能。对。有很多方法可以解开费米悖论。我们能说的一切就是，我们确实寻找过了。我们有一个叫做SETI的项目——搜寻地外文明计划。我们使用射电望远镜。
And we have a look
We haven't seen anything
We haven't heard
As soon as he said SETI, I thought you got real close.
Oh, my God.
He started when he said hot and dense at the start of the show
because it reminded him of his first boyfriend.
Setti almost finished you off.
我们观察过了。我们什么也没看见。我们什么也没听到。他一说出“SETI”（搜寻地外文明），我就觉得你离真相太近了。天哪。他节目刚开始时说“又热又稠”，因为那让他想起了他的初恋。一个SETI差点把你送走。
We've done black holes as well.
Yeah, black holes.
Oh, please don't.
I got the blood flowing.
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
But I will say this, Brian.
And I saw this, not to bring it up, I saw this, you know, this,
我们刚才还聊了黑洞呢。对，黑洞。哦，请别提了。我的血都涌上来了。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。不过我要说的是，布莱恩。我看到过这个——不是故意要提起它，我看到过这个，
I don't know if you guys have ever listened to the telepathy tapes.
There's a wonderful podcast that talks about these nonverbal people
who are able to seemingly, seemingly communicate with each other hundreds
and if not a thousand miles away from each other in ways that are very sort of provable.
And I've since seen a cut of this documentary that is absolutely stunning.
that actually shows that
and that they are able to communicate in a way
that we can't understand
我不知道你们有没有听过《心灵感应磁带》。这是一个非常精彩的播客，讲述了这些非语言交流的人，他们似乎能够在数百甚至数千英里外以非常真实可证的方式彼此进行交流。我后来看到了一段这个纪录片的剪辑，简直惊为天人。它确实展示了这一点，他们能够以一种我们无法理解的方式进行交流，
not even like that we can't comprehend
meaning that with all of our reason
we can't seem to accept
that they're able to do this
and so people say no it's bullshit
and yet they are communicating
and that's what I meant about this other dimension Brian
that potentially exists
甚至不是我们无法理解其含义，而是以我们的理性似乎无法接受他们能够做到这一点，所以人们说这都是废话，然而他们确实在交流。这就是我所说的那个可能存在的另一个维度的意思，布莱恩，
that we don't appreciate
there is an argument against that
is, if I did it, about 30 seconds, is that the particles out of which we are made.
So each of us, we're only made out of three things, actually.
Two things, an up quarks, down quarks and electrons.
Yeah.
Donuts.
So three particles.
我们对此一无所知。对此有一个反驳的观点是，如果我来解释的话，大约30秒钟，那就是构成我们的粒子。所以我们每个人，实际上只由三种东西构成。两种东西，上夸克、下夸克和电子。是的。甜甜圈。所以是三种粒子。
And we understand in massive detail how they interact with each other, how they, the forces of nature that stick them together.
We try, we look for other forces of nature.
I worked at the Large Adron Collider at CERN in Geneva.
It's a 27, well, 16 miles circumference thing.
I want to talk about that.
We're looking for anything that's a different, a new force of nature, new particles.
And we haven't seen anything.
So what most scientists would say in response is that we understand perfectly how particles
我们极其详细地了解它们是如何相互作用的，它们是如何……将它们黏合在一起的自然力。我们努力寻找其他自然力。我曾在日内瓦CERN的大型强子对撞机工作过。那是一个周长27英里——好吧，16英里的环形装置。我想聊聊这个。我们在寻找任何不同的、新的自然力或新粒子。而我们什么也没看到。所以大多数科学家对此的回应是，我们完全了解粒子是如何相互作用的，
interact, how the particles that make of our bodies.
in the conditions that we find ourselves,
which are these conditions here on Earth.
So I think your use of the word seemingly was excellent.
Right.
I like that.
That was the correct hedge.
And so you don't think it's possible that humans are aliens from another world,
构成我们身体的粒子在我们发现自己的这些条件下是如何相互作用的——也就是地球上的这些条件。所以我认为你用“似乎”这个词用得太妙了。对。我喜欢那样。那是恰当的留白。所以你不认为人类是来自另一个世界的造物，那种理论吗？
that whole theory?
It is, that's called panspermia?
Is that another one?
Yeah, yeah.
Penspermia.
I'm going to set you answer as well.
So there is...
Penspermia.
这是真的，那叫“胚种论”吗？那是另一个吗？对，对。胚种论。我也要让你回答这个问题。所以有……胚种论。
So there is an idea that, you know,
we know that there are Martian meteorites on Earth, for example.
There are bits of Mars that have fallen on Earth,
bits of Earth will have fallen on Mars.
So there are people who thought,
well, could it be that life began on Mars
and then got transferred to Earth on a meteorite or something?
Most...
所以有一种观点认为，你知道，我们知道地球上存在火星陨石，例如。有些火星碎片落到了地球上，地球碎片也会落到火星上。所以有些人认为，有没有可能生命起源于火星，然后通过陨石或其他什么东西转移到了地球上？大多数……
We don't think that.
We've got no evidence for that,
but it's not absolutely impossible.
So, yeah,
So it's possible that we're Martians.
It's unlikely.
And did you see the movie?
You saw the movie Contact, right?
我们不这样认为。我们没有这方面的证据，但这并非完全不可能。所以，是的，所以我们是火星人是有可能的。这不太可能。你看过那部电影吗？你看过电影《超时空接触》对吧？
I love it.
Carl Sagan is one of my...
That's another answer to Will's question
about why I got into science.
One of them is Carl Sagan's cosmos.
So if you remember...
Remember with Jody Foster?
So in the movie, they're interviewing...
我超爱。卡尔·萨根是我的……这也是威尔关于我为什么进入科学界的问题的另一个答案。其中之一就是卡尔·萨根的《宇宙》。如果你还记得……还记得朱迪·福斯特吗？所以在电影里，他们在采访……
Remember?
They're interviewing.
they're interviewing scientists
about what's the one question
they are going to ask these alien beings
when they get there
and what would be the question you would ask
Does planet Earth make me look fat?
还记得吗？他们在采访。他们在采访科学家，问他们见到那些外星生命时要问的第一个问题是什么，而你会问的问题会是什么？地球行星让我看起来显胖吗？
Right.
Like what would you want to know?
I...
The first thing is I'd be relieved
that there were any aliens.
I'd really say
thank God for that
because I'm very
对吧？就像你想知道什么一样？我……第一件事是，我会为终于有外星人存在而感到释怀。我真的会说，感谢上帝，因为我很
I'm worried that
imagine you go back to what we said earlier
if we're the only intelligent life
for
thousands or millions of light years
in every direction
let's say in the Milky Way galaxy
if we are
担心，想象一下回到我们刚才所说的，如果我们是四面八方成千上万或数百万光年内唯一的智能生命——假设在银河系中，如果我们是的话，
imagine the responsibility that we have
so I would be pretty relieved
if somebody else also had that responsibility
to carry the torch for intelligence
and therefore meaning in the galaxy
Right, right, right, right.
So I'd say, I'm relieved about this.
You'd take a vacation, and you'd immediately go on holidays where you're saying.
想象一下我们肩负的责任。所以如果还有其他人也承担着在银河系中延续智慧和因此延续意义的火炬的责任，我会感到相当宽慰。对，对，对，对。所以我会说，我对这一点感到如释重负。你会去度假，你会立刻去度假，然后你会说……
Well, you'd say, yeah, we can just relax.
And then, but I'd like to know how they got through these problems that we have.
You know, at the moment we, you know, we talk about AI, and we talk about the threat,
and we've still got nuclear weapons and those things.
So we've got all these problems to navigate before we make it to the stars.
So I actually would say, how did you not blow yourselves up?
How did you not mess it?
up before you became an interstellar civilization.
嗯，你会说，好吧，我们终于可以放松一下了。然后，但我很想知道他们是如何克服我们目前面临的这些问题的。你知道，目前我们，你知道，我们谈论人工智能，我们谈论威胁，我们仍然有核武器以及诸如此类的事情。所以在我们通往群星之前，我们还有所有这些问题需要去解决。所以我其实会想问：你们是怎么做到没有把自己炸毁的？在你们成为一个星际文明之前，你们是怎么做到没有把事情搞砸的？
That's a good question, yeah.
It is amazing that if we are made of just what those three elements.
So it's all sort of science and various combinations and recipes of all these little elements
in the atmosphere that made this intelligent life form.
It's amazing that nowhere else in the entire universe has a combination of various elements
come together to create another sort of living, breathing, thinking thing that might not look
like us.
Because it seems somewhat arbitrary that just, you know, based on like just sort of cooking
这是一个好问题，是的。令人惊叹的是，如果我们仅仅由那三种元素构成。所以这一切都是科学，以及大气中所有这些小元素的各种组合和配方，造就了这种有智慧的生命形式。令人惊叹的是，在整个宇宙的其他任何地方，竟然没有通过各种元素的组合来创造出另一种可能长得不像我们的、有血有肉有思考能力的生物。因为这看起来有点随兴所欲，仅仅基于烹饪
and a recipe that those little three elements came together and out of the slime, out of the
algae over the years of evolution, we became like that that didn't come together and in some
other forms somewhere else too.
Oh, yeah.
I agree with you.
I'm sure even in the universe we can see with those two trillion galaxies in it.
I'm sure it's happened, you know, out there.
Right, right, right.
和食谱，那三种微小的元素就组合在了一起，经过多年的演化，从粘液中、从藻类中，我们变成了这样，而这些元素在其他地方的某些其他形式中却没有组合在一起。哦，是的。我同意你的看法。我敢肯定，即使在我们能看到的那个拥有两万亿个星系的宇宙中，这种事肯定也已经在其他地方发生过了，你知道的。对，对，对。
The question really is how far do we have to go to see another world where it happened?
And you're right, what you said, actually, you could turn it around.
Because you're right, is these three particles.
And over 13 and a half billion years, that somehow these particles have got together in a pattern that can have a conversation.
that's quite a big ask
you put it like that
so that's the other way to look at it
you talked about you
真正的问题是，我们要走多远才能看到另一个发生过这种事的星球？你说得对，其实你可以换个角度来看。因为你说的对，就是这三种粒子。在135亿年的时间里，这些粒子不知怎么地以某种能够进行对话的模式聚集在了一起。如果你这样说的话，这要求可真不小，所以这是另一种看待方式。你刚才谈到你……
I only have a few minutes left of your time
and God bless you for
hanging in there with us
I love it I could chat to you
I love it too
I seriously could talk to you for hours
let me see
what's a scientific fact
我只有几分钟时间了，非常感谢你能坚持陪我们聊到现在。我太喜欢了，我可以跟你……我也太喜欢了。我真的能跟你聊上好几个小时。让我看看，有什么科学事实
you know is true but still find
impossible to emotionally process
Oh, there's almost all of it, you know, we've talked about a lot of it.
I mean, just that idea, as we said earlier, the billions of stars.
But also, you know, I got a friend who's a physicist who I work with a lot of the university at Manchester.
And he said to me, the most incredible thing of all is that anything exists.
Right.
So ultimately, it's the fact that, I mean, it's obviously an age-old philosophical question.
你知道它是真的，但你仍然觉得在情感上无法接受？哦，几乎全都是这样，你知道的，我们已经聊了很多。我的意思是，仅仅是那个概念，就像我们刚才说的，数以亿计的恒星。还有，你知道的，我有个物理学家朋友，我和他在曼彻斯特大学经常合作。他曾对我说，最不可思议的事情莫过于任何东西居然都存在。对。所以归根结底，这个事实——我的意思是，这显然是一个古老的哲学问题。
Right.
But it astonishes me that anything exists.
It really astonished me what Jason said a few minutes ago,
that these little particles have managed to get together into patterns
that can have conversations and bring meaning to the universe in a very real sense.
That amazes me as well.
How do you keep from getting, like if I was in your line of work,
which is basically probing for answers to questions,
对。但任何东西的存在都让我感到震惊。几分钟前杰森说的话也真正让我震惊，这些微小的粒子竟然能够组合成能够进行对话的模式，并在一个非常真实的意义上为宇宙带来意义。这也同样让我惊叹。你平时是怎么让自己不至于……如果我和你从事同样的行业——基本上就是不断追问问题的答案，
I personally would have sort of this looming sort of angst
and potential depression,
that I know I'm in a field
that I'm never, ever going to know the answers to all of it.
And it's just like somebody who, like, specializes in the afterlife.
Well, you're never going to really know what happens until after you die.
And then it's too late to come back and let us all know.
That is my next question, I swear to God.
我个人可能会产生某种隐隐的焦虑和潜在的抑郁，因为我知道我身处一个永远、永远不可能知道所有答案的领域。这就像一个专门研究死后世界的人一样。好吧，你永远不会真正知道死后会发生什么，直到你死去。而到了那时，再回来告诉我们大家已经太迟了。这就是我的下一个问题，我向上帝发誓。
It's the key that is the key to science this.
So, you know, at the end of my live show, actually,
I say that what's the key?
what's a progress. So first of all, progress, you have to admit, you have to admit that you don't know things
by definition, right? You can't make progress if you think you know everything. So people who think
they know everything are going to be a barrier to progress, right, first. But secondly, I say,
we have to stand on the edge of the known and look out into the unknown, not with fear,
but with delight and excitement. Because it's the delight and excitement of not knowing.
这就是科学的关键所在。所以，你知道的，实际上在我的现场表演结束时，我会说关键是什么？什么是进步。首先，进步，你必须承认，按定义来说，你必须承认自己不知道很多事情，对吧？如果你觉得自己无所不知，你就无法取得进步。所以那些自以为无所不知的人将成为进步的障碍，这是第一点。但其次，我说，我们必须站在已知事物的边缘，望向未知，不是带着恐惧，而是带着喜悦和兴奋。因为正是这种“不知道”的喜悦和兴奋，
That's the key to science.
So you turn it around and you're excited about looking out into the darkness because of the things that you might find, the treasure that's buried somewhere in the darkness.
And you get comfortable with the fact that you'll never reach the end of that line of questions.
Yeah, because then it would be, in some ways, because it's so wonderful and delightful to not know things and to have things to find out, it would be, the greatest fear might be that we,
end up knowing everything
because then it would be utterly pointless.
Yeah, you need a reason to get out of bed.
So tell me what in your sign...
才是科学的关键。所以你扭转心态，因为你可能会在黑暗中发现某些东西、某处埋藏在黑暗中的宝藏，而对凝视黑暗感到兴奋。并且你要习惯这样一个事实：你永远无法走到那串问题的尽头。是的，因为那样的话，在某种程度上——因为“不知道”以及有东西要去发现是如此美妙和令人愉悦，最大的恐惧可能反而是我们最终无所不知，因为那样的话就彻底毫无意义了。是的，你需要一个早上起床的理由。那么告诉我，在你的科学……
Remember when Jody Foster?
Just remember that moment?
I love that film.
It's one of my favorite films of all.
No way, no way.
Sean, what?
You see it?
It is, though.
还记得朱迪·福斯特吗？还记得那个时刻吗？我太喜欢那部电影了。那是我最喜欢的电影之一。绝无仅有，绝无仅有。肖恩，什么？你看过吗？确实如此。
Everything about that film is brilliant.
Brilliant, right?
What?
So in your scientific opinion, what happens?
when we die, which is kind of what Jason just touched on.
Oh, boy.
I mean, my view is that we die.
So it's like...
那部电影的方方面面都太棒了。太棒了，对吧？什么？所以以你的科学观点来看，当我们死后会发生什么？这有点像杰森刚才触及的话题。哦，天哪。我的看法是，我们死了就死了。所以就像是……
And that's it.
It goes back to what we said earlier.
If the brain is just this somehow...
I don't mean just right.
It's a remarkable computer that's evolved over four billion years, but it's a computer.
Maybe you turn the computer off.
You don't ask what's happening inside the computer.
We know what's happening inside the computer.
就是这样。这又回到了我们刚才说的话题。如果大脑只是这样某种……我不是指刚刚好。它是一台经过四十亿年演化而成的神奇计算机，但它归根结底还是一台计算机。也许你把计算机关掉。你不会去问计算机里面正在发生什么。我们都知道计算机里面在发生什么。
It's nothing.
So it goes back to all the questions we would disqualify.
discussing. So otherwise, I suppose you have to imagine there's something else other than the
particles out of which we're made, call it a soul or whatever you want to call it, but there's
something else that we've not detected any evidence for. There's something else. That's
what you have to... Yeah, it's like a... It's like Jason going back. It's kind of like a Biza
at the end of the summer, like the party's done, but the vibe continues on. Like the vibe, the
fine keeps going you know what i mean but then but then what's the most thing that is i don't find it
什么都没有。所以这又回到了我们本该不予讨论的那些问题。否则的话，我想你不得不去想象，除了构成我们的那些粒子之外，还有别的东西，称之为灵魂或者随便你叫它什么，但那是我们从未检测到任何证据的某种东西。还有别的东西。这就是你不得不……对，就像一个……就像杰森回去一样。有点像夏天结束时的伊比沙岛，就像派对结束了，但那种氛围仍在继续。就像那种氛围，那种律动一直在持续，你知道我的意思吗，但是随后，随后的那件最主要的事情是，我并不觉得它
frightening though i find it wonderful i mean in in a sense it means that we have this finite time
in which to enjoy ourselves and explore the universe and live right so i think that's enough i find
that uplifting do you live for tomorrow or do you live for today knowing that that's a good question
one one one surely good for you will you got on the board
Surely both, don't we?
It goes back to that question.
I was thinking about this either day.
Imagine you know everything.
可怕，相反我觉得它很美妙。我的意思是，从某种意义上说，这意味着我们有这么一段有限的时间来享受生活、探索宇宙并好好活着，对吧？所以我觉得这就够了，我发现这很令人振奋。你是为明天而活，还是为今天而活，既然明知——这是个好问题。有一个人，绝对对你有好处，你上榜了。当然是两者兼有，对吧？这又回到了那个问题。我前几天还在想这个。想象一下你无所不知。
That's what we were just talking about.
If you know everything, it means you know what's going to happen.
So what kind of a life is that?
If you knew what was going to happen tomorrow,
I think our existence might be pointless.
In fact, that's what I think.
The key to our enjoyment of the universe is our enjoyment of life
is not knowing what's coming.
这就是我们刚才在讨论的。如果你无所不知，那就意味着你知道接下来会发生什么。那算什么生活呢？如果你知道明天会发生什么，我觉我们的存在可能会变得毫无意义。事实上，我就是这么想的。我们享受宇宙、享受人生的关键，就在于不知道接下来会发生什么。
If you knew, what would you do?
How would you live if you knew?
That's why I like to believe that whatever our eternal battery is,
like whatever keeps our, we don't have gasoline or battery power inside our body,
but somehow our heart keeps beating.
Yeah, that blows my mind.
So whatever is fueling us, and I like to think that it's sort of a friend of
or part of our consciousness.
如果你知道了，你会怎么做？如果你知道了，你将如何生活？这就是为什么我愿意相信，无论我们的永恒电池是什么，比如无论是什么在维持我们的——我们体内可没有汽油或电池供电，但不知为何我们的心脏一直在跳动。是的，这太让我震撼了。所以，无论是什么在为我们提供能量，我倾向于认为它某种程度上是我们的意识的朋友，或者是我们意识的一部分。
Our consciousness is like this thing that it's sort of, it's in the ether.
and that when our vehicle runs out of fuel,
dies, our body dies, runs out of time,
that consciousness, those thoughts, those feelings,
that it can travel and maybe either occupy another body
or a dog or a tree or whatever,
that it keeps, there's this perpetual sort of loop
that this consciousness does and it advances
我们的意识就像是这样一种东西，它某种程度上存在于太空中。当我们的躯体燃料耗尽而死去，我们的身体死亡、时间耗尽时，那种意识、那些思想、那些情感，能够去旅行，也许去占据另一个躯体、一只狗、一棵树或诸如此类的东西，它会保持下去，这种意识会进行一种永恒的循环，并且在它每次
each time it goes through a body or a being
or an object or something.
Well, I like to think that it kind of dissipates into the, you know,
that we're all connected.
Combines.
Yeah.
And then at a certain point, it becomes sort of our turn.
经历一个躯体、一个生命、一个物体或某种东西时都会得到提升。嗯，我倾向于认为它有点消散在……你知道的，我们都是相连的。结合在一起。对。对。然后在某个时刻，某种程度上就轮到我们了。
And then it sort of, it does all into the rest of the universe.
Yeah, I feel connected to the universe.
I feel like I'm removing the magic if I say that,
Sean answered the question.
When he said, what's fueling us?
I just thought, donuts.
Yeah.
You said it earlier.
然后它某种程度上，融入了宇宙的其他部分。是的，我觉得自己与宇宙相连。如果我说这话，我觉得我是在剥离魔法，肖恩回答了这个问题。当他说，是什么在给我们提供能量时？我当时脑子里只想到了甜甜圈。对。你刚才也这么说来着。
So that is actually technically shocked.
Sean, what did you have breakfast for breakfast today?
I haven't eaten yet.
What?
I know.
But what do you think it will be?
I'm probably going to have eggs and toast today
and also maybe like a yogurt drink.
所以实际上严格来说就是这样。肖恩，你今天早饭吃的是什么？我还没吃呢。什么？我知道。但你觉得会是什么？我今天大概会吃鸡蛋和吐司，可能还会喝点酸奶饮料。
That's it, though.
That's what's fueling us.
And then the answer to the question about what happens.
Obviously, it's a wonderful question, is it?
But the thing is, it's like saying what happens to zoom
when we turn the computer off.
We keep zooming.
I don't think we did.
不过也就这些了。这就是给我们提供能量的东西。然后关于会发生什么的答案。显然，这是一个美妙的问题，对吧？但问题是，这就好像在问当我们把计算机关掉时，Zoom会怎么样。我们一直在Zoom。我觉得我们并没有。
though. I think when you turn the computer off, Zoom stocks.
Will's going to love this and then we're going to let you go.
You are a season ticket at Oldham Athletic soccer team, right?
Yeah. Well, I was.
Oh, I thought you still were.
No, I used to be. It's my local club, my local football club.
Oh, wow. How about that?
Who do you support now?
不过。我觉得当你把计算机关掉时，Zoom就停止了。威尔会喜欢这个的，然后我们要让你走了。你是奥尔德姆竞技足球俱乐部的季票持有者，对吧？对。嗯，我曾经是。哦，我以为你现在还是。不，我以前是。那是我的本地俱乐部，我的本地足球俱乐部。哦，哇。那怎么样？你现在支持谁？
Oldham.
Yeah. And that's it.
We're famous. Oldham Athletic are famous for being the only club in history
to have been in the Premier League.
So we're in the Premier League
with Man United and Liverpool and that.
And then we got relegated
奥尔德姆。奥尔德姆。对。就是这样。我们很有名。奥尔德姆竞技因成为历史上唯一一支曾参加过英超联赛却又一路降级
out of the entire football league.
Wow, all the way down.
All the way down.
But last year, and I was at the game,
we got promoted back into the Football League again.
Wow.
So now we're in the lowest division of the football league.
Which is what?
跌出整个足球联盟的俱乐部而闻名。哇，一路降到底。一路到底。但去年，我当时就在比赛现场，我们又重新升入了足球联盟。哇。所以现在我们处于足球联盟的最低级别。那是第几级？
Four divisions?
Eight?
Yeah.
Wow.
We went all the way down
into what we call non-league.
So that's kind of our claim to fame.
四个级别？八个？对。八个？哇。我们一路降级到了我们所谓的非联赛级别。所以这就是我们的成名之处。
But we're on our way back.
J.B., that's your nickname.
Isn't it? Oldham?
Bride, thank you so much for being here.
You know, he spelled Old Ham.
Old Ham?
That's how he spelled, you know?
Also my name.
但我们在回来的路上了。J.B.，那是你的昵称。对吧？奥尔德姆？布赖恩，非常感谢你能来。你知道，他把Old Ham拼成了Old Ham。Old Ham？他是这么拼的，你知道吗？这也是我的名字。
I know you just got back from Australia.
You've probably got to be exhausted.
Thank you for being here.
And the next tour, it's called Emergence right now, your tour?
Yeah.
And I really, is that the one that's going to come to Los Angeles?
Yeah, yeah, I'll be in L.A., you know.
across America towards the end of this year and three next year.
我知道你刚从澳大利亚回来。你现在肯定精疲力竭了。谢谢你能来。你的下一场巡演，现在叫“崛起”巡演，对吧？对。我真的，那是要去洛杉矶的那场吗？对，对，我会去洛杉矶，你知道的。今年年底和明年会有三场穿梭美国的巡演。
I can't wait.
Can't wait for that.
You're very kind to speak to us today.
Thank you for putting up with our questions.
Yeah.
Have we got anywhere though?
我等不及了。等不及了。你今天能和我们谈话真是太好了。谢谢你忍受我们的提问。对。对。不过我们聊出个所以然了吗？对。
We never do.
We never get anywhere.
We're smart more.
We're smart more today.
Yeah.
Thanks, Brian.
Thanks so much.
It was such a pleasure to meet you.
我们从来没有。我们从来没聊出个所以然。我们今天变得更聪明了一点。对。谢谢你，布赖恩。非常感谢。很高兴能见到你。
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Brian.
See you later.
Thanks, bye.
Wow.
He's like the guy now.
now. Like he's the guy everybody talks to. He's always in my feed and I'm like stop and I listen
非常感谢。谢谢你，布赖恩。谢谢你，布赖恩。回头见。谢谢，再见。哇。他现在就像是个大红人。现在。就像他是每个人都在谈论的那个人。他总是出现在我的信息流里，然后我就停下来听
to what he says, you know, my Instagram feed. I'm really interested to see what the format of his show
is. He says there's a big screen there, which I guess is, you know, supports some of the answers
that he's talking about with some pictures and things like that. Yeah. Wouldn't it be cool to go?
Yeah, let's do it. Let's get all gummed up and get there. Yeah, I would love that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. I guess I'm driving. I would love it. I also wanted to ask
about CERN, which I didn't get to, you know.
Wait, are we allowed now to bring on academics now?
Because I've got some ideas for like, you know.
他说的话，你知道的，我的Instagram动态。我很想看看他的节目形式是什么样的。他说那里有一个大屏幕，我想这大概是（你知道的）配合他所谈论的一些答案，展示一些图片之类的内容。对。去现场不是很酷吗？对，我们去吧。让我们嗨起来去现场吧。对，我很乐意。哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。我想是我来开车吧。我很乐意。我还想问关于欧洲核子研究中心的事，我没来得及问，你知道的。等等，我们现在可以邀请学者上节目了吗？因为我有一些关于……你知道的……的想法。
Of course.
Some smarties like that again.
I felt like we kind of like went away from that.
And it was like, um, celebs only.
But like, yeah, let's let's bring in some like some brain food.
Yeah.
I love that.
Which is not to say our celebrities are not smart people.
当然。又是一些像那样的高智商人士。我感觉我们之前有点偏离这个方向了。就好像，嗯，只有名人。但是，好吧，让我们请一些……精神食粮来吧。对。我喜欢这样。这并不是说我们的名人就不是聪明人。
No, no, no, no.
We're not suggesting that.
Yeah.
But I like, I like this.
I'll bring on some artists.
and some...
I love it.
Yeah, I love...
不，不，不，不。我们可没这么暗示。对。但我喜欢，我喜欢这样。我会请一些艺术家来，还有……我喜欢。对，我喜欢……
I could talk to that guy all day long.
The, um...
Did you guys know...
His nightmare is you talking to him
all day long, by the way.
I'm sure.
He looks on his phone that just somehow just
rang.
我可以和那家伙聊上一整天。那个……你们知道吗……顺便说一句，他的噩梦就是你和他聊上一整天。我敢肯定。他看了看他的手机，手机刚好响了。
So we never got to tattooing.
Is it real?
Yeah, I know.
We should have him back
once we all get a chance
to see Disclosure Day, you know?
Yeah, I'm seeing it right after this.
No way, really?
所以我们始终没聊到纹身。那是真的吗？对，我知道。等我们都有机会去看《解密日》的时候，我们应该把他请回来，你知道吗？对，我看完这个马上就去看。真的假的？
I'm hanging up with you guys.
I'm seeing it.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
A matinee.
I love it.
Just so you can't be,
just so no one bothers you,
我要和你们挂电话了。我要去看。对。哦，天哪。一场日场电影。我喜欢。为了不被打扰，为了不让任何人烦你，
That's exactly right.
You'd be alone in the theater?
Yeah, I love it.
What are you gonna eat at the theater?
Yeah.
I'm probably gonna have some popcorn.
I'm gonna eat good.
I have to start eating better.
完全正确。你要一个人坐在影院里？对，我喜欢。你打算在影院吃点什么？对。我大概会吃点爆米花。我要吃得好一点。我得开始吃得健康一点了。
Why?
You got a big, big,
sex scene coming up?
No, I feel like my blood is creme brulee.
I texted that to you.
And I think it is.
Yeah, it's all as fat and sugar and salt.
What is your go-to at a movie theater?
为什么？你接下来有一场非常重要的激情戏吗？没有，我觉得我的血液都变成焦糖布丁了。我把这发信息告诉你了。我觉得确实如此。对，全都是脂肪、糖和盐。你看电影时的首选是什么？
You have popcorn and then do you buy some candy
and you like sprinkle it on top?
If I could, I'd get pretzel bites with cheese.
I'd dip the pretzel bites in the cheese.
Geez.
Yeah.
That's the best.
That answer was so quick.
你吃爆米花，然后会买点糖果撒在上面吗？如果可以的话，我会买带芝士的蝴蝶饼球。我会把蝴蝶饼球蘸着芝士吃。天哪。对。那是最好的。那个回答太快了。
Yeah.
Do you put, you,
do you,
one of those guys
that likes a few pumps
of butter sauce
on your,
on your popcorn?
对。你会放，你，你会，你是那种喜欢在爆米花上挤几下黄油酱的人吗？
Few pumps.
Butter sauce,
I think was your handle
in high school,
right?
A few pumps.
Butter sauce.
Hey, guys,
几下。黄油酱，我想这就是你高中的外号吧，对不对？几下。黄油酱。嘿，伙计们，
look who's coming down
the hogs,
butter sauce.
Here comes old butt sauce.
Hey,
do you,
what is it what's your what's your go to when you when you like fucking stomach up to the the old counter there
看谁走过来了，黄油酱。老屁股酱来啦。嘿，你，你，你走到柜台前时的首选是什么？
hey hi if i could hey guys it's buts us can i get you know what i get i went to i went to the movies
by myself for the first time in a long time a few weeks ago i went so i went saw the project
oh yeah yeah i'm mary why didn't you talk about that with brian cox well because we were
talking about it wasn't it good yeah so good and and uh and uh and uh and uh and uh and uh i'm
old uh brine gosling did a great job brian gosling did a great job and uh he's so good i like that guy he's amazing
he's so good and then uh and it's our buddies phil lord and chris miller who made the movie shout out to those guys we love those guys
but i went to the theater by myself to see it and i got a large popcorn with a peanut emmps and i put them in the popcorn the thing yeah that's what i get that
now and then so did you did you kill that large popcorn i sure did and and can i can i can i can i can i can i ask you if the if the
嘿，嗨，如果可以的话——嘿，伙计们，我是屁股酱，我可以——你知道我吃什么吗？几周前我很久以来第一次一个人去看电影，我去看了——所以我去看了那个项目。哦，对，对，麦瑞，你为什么不和布赖恩·考克斯聊聊这个？嗯，因为我们在聊别的，不是吗？对，太棒了。太棒了，还有……还有……还有……还有……还有……奥尔德姆……布赖恩·高斯林做得真棒，布赖恩·高斯林做得真棒，而且……他太棒了，我喜欢那家伙，他太棒了，他太棒了，然后……还有我们的好哥们菲尔·洛德和克里斯·米勒拍了这部电影，向那几位致敬，我们爱那几位，但我是自己一个人去影院看的，我买了一大桶爆米花和一包花生M&M豆，我把它们倒进爆米花里，就是这样。对，我现在偶尔也会这样。所以，你，你把那大桶爆米花吃光了吗？我当然吃光了。而且，我能，我能，我能，我能，我能，我能问你，
if your morning routine the next day was the same?
Were you okay?
I was okay.
Yeah, I was okay.
I felt it when I woke up.
I felt it when I got out.
I felt super...
What do you mean?
第二天早上的晨间程序还和往常一样吗？你没事吧？我没事。对，我没事。我醒来时感觉到了。我出门时感觉到了。我觉得超级……你什么意思？
Just the sugar and the crash of all that garbage
and a large soda and I just felt crummy
and I went home and I went to bed.
And then I woke up and I...
Jay, did you usually just bring a bowl of nuts
with you to the theater?
I do.
Sure.
就是那些糖分和所有这些垃圾食品带来的疲惫感，还有一大杯苏打水，我感觉糟透了，然后我回家上床睡觉了。然后我醒来，我……杰伊，你通常只会带一碗坚果去影院吗？我确实带。当然。
It's a true.
trail mix. It's a Ziploc bag with some trail mix.
Yeah, that Amanda organized for you.
No, I enjoy the popcorn. I just can't
have a lot of it because
then it wrecks my routine in the morning,
if you know what I mean.
I don't really, just elaborate.
那是真的。什锦干果。带点什锦干果的自封袋。对，阿曼达帮你准备的。不，我很喜欢爆米花。我只是不能吃太多，因为那样会打乱我早上的作息，如果你懂我的意思的话。我其实不太懂，展开说说。
Yeah, well, it's a binder
is what it is. Okay, got it.
Got it. Yeah, yeah. It's a binder.
But, oh boy, I like that
guest. Thank you, Sean. Yeah, yeah, I love
it too. And speaking of, what does popcorn
do to you? What is it? It's a real
binders.
好吧，其实就是通便剂，就是这样。好吧，明白了。明白了。对，对。是个通便剂。但是，天哪，我喜欢那个嘉宾。谢谢你，肖恩。对，对，我也很喜欢。说到这个，爆米花对你有什么影响？那是什么？真是个强力通便剂。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smartless.
Smartless由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆贾夫100%有机手工制作。Smartless。